It’s the late 90's, and an Air Canada flight
experiences severe malfunctions while traveling
from London to Vancouver.
The pilots are unable to do anything and the
plane crashes into the woods of Northern Alberta.
The crash was devastating - only 10 of the
nearly 300 people on board are alive.
And even though they survived the initial
disaster, their battle for life has only just
begun.
It’s late autumn in Northern Canada and
there’s no telling when help will arrive,
if at all.
If the survivors want to make it through the
night they need to find shelter, and fast.
As they trudge through the freezing woods,
the group finds a path that looks like it
might lead them to civilization.
After all, if there was a path in the woods,
that meant they were probably in a national
park, and if they were in a national park,
there had to be a ranger's station around
somewhere where they could warm up and call
for help.
They didn’t have many other options, so
they followed the path which opened up to
a clearing, but instead of finding a ranger's
station or campground, they found something
none of them could have expected.
It was a pond, but there was something off
about it.
As they got closer they saw that this strange
pond wasn’t filled with water, but blood.
The survivors were horrified.
That couldn't really be blood, could it?
It must be a weird algae or a chemical reaction.
But one member of the group, a man named Thomas
Dean, who had been on his way back to his
hometown of Prince George, British Columbia,
thought there was something strangely familiar
about this.
He remembered being a boy and going to visit
family in Alberta, and hearing an urban legend
from the older local kids.
According to the stories, somewhere out in
the wilderness, in the northern part of the
province, there was a pond full of human blood,
and what made it even worse, was that some
said the pond was a gateway to hell.
The SCP Foundation was also aware of this
legend, and had been trying to pinpoint the
exact source of it for decades prior to the
Air Canada crash.
They would finally receive definite confirmation
of the blood pond when Foundation personnel
intercepted a radio transmission from a ranger's
station located within the Wood Buffalo National
Park.
It was the survivors of the crash, who had
managed to make it through the night, and
they were about to be escorted out of the
park by rangers.
The Foundation mobilized quickly to cordon
off the pond, as at this time they were unsure
of what potentially harmful properties the
pond might have had.
They set up Watch Station Epsilon-38 and put
staff on guard to deter travellers from the
area.
The pond was given the designation of SCP-354
and classed as Euclid.
Foundation scientists made a number of interesting
discoveries about SCP-354 when they collected
samples for testing.
First, the pond was not in fact full of blood,
merely an inorganic liquid that closely resembles
blood in color and consistently.
Second, and even stranger than the red liquid,
is that the pond doesn't seem to have definite
banks or a bottom.
Instead, the liquid in the pond increases
in density as the radius away from the center
increases - the liquid congeals at the edges,
becoming more solid and blending into the
surrounding soil.
It also becomes thicker as one descends deeper
into the pool, and a bottom of the pond has
not yet been reached, if it even exists.
Initially, the foundation found no signs of
life within the blood pond.
But that would all change at 2:03 PM on the
day following the opening of Watch Station
Epsilon-38, when the science team noticed
an unusual level of activity on the pond's
surface.
Security footage feeds showed a shape rising
up out of the pond, followed by a deafening
shriek.
After that, the feed was cut and Foundation
lost all communication with Watch Station
Epsilon-38.
Fearing the worst, a Mobile Task Force was
dispatched to the location.
When they got there, all personnel at the
watch station had been killed by what could
only be described as a gigantic bat.
The task force was able to neutralize the
entity, and as soon as they could, the Foundation
moved in to increase security around the SCP,
creating Area - 354 and installing a permanent
security detail.
After this point, the pond started to regularly
spit out a variety of monstrous entities,
almost as if it was reacting to the SCP Foundation's
increased security measures.
After SCP-354-1, the giant bat came SCP-354-2.
354-2 was an echidna-like monster the size
of a bear, that was virtually bulletproof
but unable to escape Area 354.
The foundation neutralized this anomaly with
napalm.
SCP-354-3 was a floating black sphere capable
of firing deadly beams of concentrated energy.
The area's head scientist was able to hit
it with a sledgehammer, causing the sphere
to malfunction and self-destruct before it
was able to escape the area.
The Foundation wasn't as lucky with SCP-354-4.
This creature was a reptilian humanoid that
stood roughly 15 feet tall and was unable
to be put down with gunfire.
This was the first creature from the pond
to successfully escape containment, and was
only able to be neutralized when the Foundation
sent in Mobile Task Force Omega 7, also known
as “Pandora's Box.”
The data on pond incursions is partially corrupted,
so a complete list of creatures is not available,
but some of the other monsters that came out
of the blood pond included a killer robot,
a set of gigantic tentacles that dragged several
D-class personnel into the pond, a pair of
panther-like creatures - one made of ice and
the other of magma - that ignored foundation
staff and instead fought each other, and one
seemingly normal human man who was executed
as soon as he emerged from the pond.
Tests on his body revealed that he was, in
fact, totally normal and would have posed
no threat.
These anomalies came out of the pond at fairly
regular intervals for several months, before
the pond went silent for an unprecedented
22 months.
The head scientist at the time noted, “I
suspect this means one of two things.
Either the Red Pool has ‘died’ or ‘powered
down’ or whatever the correct term for it
is; or it is ‘charging up’ for something
big to come through.
O5 believes the former is the most likely
explanation, and has recalled 30% of our total
personnel and cut 25% of our funding.
While I can only hope that they are correct,
if the latter situation is true, we're soon
to face some terrible monstrosity and we won't
have anywhere near the force necessary to
deal with it.
I worry for all of our safety.”
His words would prove eerily prophetic following
the events of Exploratory Mission 354 Alpha.
The Foundation's research and development
team built a specialized craft to explore
the pond.
Because of the strange properties of the pond's
density, the craft was essentially made to
be both a submarine, for parts of the pond
where the contents were liquid, and a drill,
for when the liquid congealed into a semi-solid
towards the bottom.
The exploration team consisted of Agent Swanson,
Agent Turquoise, Agent 86, Dr. Jay Macarthur,
Chris Simmons, Leroy Tucker, and a pilot named
Marty.
With the team assembled, the ship was sent
down into the pond.
Nothing eventful happened for the first two
days of the mission, but at 4:30 AM on the
third day, gravity suddenly reversed for the
crew of the ship.
This seemed to indicate that they were approaching
the halfway point, though what would be on
the other side, nobody could say.
On the fourth day, the ship surfaced, proving
definitely that the pond was in fact some
sort of portal.
The crew looked out of the portholes to see
the darkness of night above them.
While sensors outside the ship detected nothing
harmful in the atmosphere around them, the
crew were wary of exiting the craft.
The other side of the pond was nothing like
the world the crew knew.
For one thing, the night lasted for 28 hours
before dawn came, and when the sun finally
rose, it was much larger and redder than the
earth's sun.
Under the light of that strange, red star,
the crew could see that the pond on this side
was massive compared to where they'd come
in - more like a large lake.
Surrounding the lake was sand and rocks that
were covered in a kind of moss that disappeared
under sunlight and regrew during the night.
The team left the ship and started to explore.
During their time in this strange world, they
found that the day lasted just a few hours
shorter than the night, meaning that whatever
planet they were on had roughly a 43-hour-long
rotation as opposed to our own planet's 24.
The team found a number of anomalous elements
on their expedition, including razor-sharp
grass that can puncture skin and streams of
liquid carbon dioxide.
They heard some loud roars in the distance
once or twice, but other than that the planet
was eerily silent, with seemingly no animal
life and not even wind.
When it rained, the soil remained dry, and
based on that, the scientists theorized plants
in this world were more efficient at absorbing
moisture.
On the 25th day, the team ran into a huge
metal wall that appeared to be artificially
constructed.
Luckily, Leroy Tucker, a quick-thinking researcher,
was able to rig a blowtorch from camping supplies
and melt a hole through the metal.
On the other side, there was finally wind,
and odd black grass.
That's the extent of what is known about the
other side of the wall, though, because the
expedition logs are heavily corrupted after
that point, but we know that whatever was
in there wasn't good, because the team never
returned.
Strangely, there's no record of any of the
names mentioned in the ship's log - almost
as if being killed on the other side completely
erased them from history.
No other expeditions into the pond were launched
after that.
On an undisclosed date, a year following the
discovery of the blood pond and construction
of Area 354, the site was completely evacuated,
and the power was cut to the area.
Mobile Task Force Theta-12 was dispatched
to investigate the cause of the evacuation,
but before contact could be established, the
area's on-site nuclear warhead was detonated,
completely destroying the site.
MTF Theta 12 was then attacked by a convoy
made up of D-class and other low-ranking staff
who had evacuated Area 354.
It was apparent that there had been some kind
of mutiny within the site, and that a dissolution
of the chain of command had led to its evacuation
and destruction.
The convoy totally annihilated MTF Theta 12,
and no further contact with the former personnel
of Area-354 has been made since.
Following the site's detonation, a new site
was constructed, called simply the Red Pool
Containment Site.
Unlike the previous facility, which focused
on research and neutralization, the new site
is entirely concerned with containment.
The shift in directive came as a response
to the pond's apparent reactive nature - each
creature that emerged from the pond seemed
to be in retaliation to the Foundation's actions,
and it was theorized by some that the mutiny
at Area 354 was triggered by some kind of
psychic attack from the pond itself.
An interview in the SCP file on 354 reveals
that there was one more disastrous attempt
to control and understand the blood pond.
According to an interview with a Foundation
agent, the head doctor proposed a scheme to
drain the blood pond using a system of pumps
and hoses.
All non-essential personnel were evacuated
in case of emergency, leaving only the pump
technicians, D-class personnel, and a few
agents for security.
However, as soon as the pump was scheduled
to be turned on, everyone at the site experienced
a mass dissociative episode.
The agent described the feeling they all experienced
as like being in a dream and suddenly realizing
that you're asleep.
He said “Everything stopped being real.
It was like we had to escape right now.”
When asked what happened when the pump was
turned on, he simply explained that it “wouldn't
let them”.
This interview confirmed the theory that the
pond is not only capable of releasing monsters
out into our world, but also that it's capable
of powerful but much more subtle, psychological
attacks.
This suggests a chilling possibility - that
the pond isn't just blindly reacting to being
attacked, but it's fully sentient, and the
actions of the SCP foundation have only served
to annoy it.
And worse, studies of the pond's banks have
provided evidence that the area of congealed
liquid around the perimeter of the pond has
been steadily expanding.
That's right - the pond is getting bigger.
The last thing the Foundation agent stationed
at the site said before being dragged out
of the interview and sedated was “It gets
bigger and stronger every day, and now we've
made it angry!”
One of the primary aims of the SCP foundation
is to contain the anomalies that they discover.
Secure, Contain, Protect is their mission
statement, after all.
However, there are some forces so unknowable
and malevolent that there is no way to truly
contain them.
SCP-4205 is one such force.
Very little is known about SCP-4205, even
compared to other SCPs, many of which are
mysterious by their very nature.
We do not know what it is, we do not know
what it wants, and we do not have any meaningful
way to stop it.
The best that can be done to protect yourself
from it is to implement the few known preventative
measures available, and pray that it doesn’t
set its sights on you.
The little information that exists on SCP-4205
was recorded by Wade Dalitz, a former junior
researcher at the Foundation.
He wrote the initial report on SCP-4205 on
a computer, Terminal 4, which was linked to
his brain and consciousness as he wrote.
Though his work was highly valuable, and provided
many previously unknown insights about the
nature of the SCP, sadly his knowledge could
not save him.
The official entry on SCP-4205 was his final
act before his death on December 11, 1992.
Before we get deeper into that entry, and
Wade’s final day on earth, it’s important
to understand what SCP-4205 is.
Or, at least, understand the little we know
about what it is.
4205 is a Keter class SCP, meaning that it’s
incredibly difficult or complicated to contain.
It also shows extreme hostility toward all
life.
It is described as an amber-colored pair of
human-like eyes, with the ability to appear
spontaneously in windows, mirrors, or any
other glass or glass-like surface.
One of the reasons so little is known about
these eyes, is that anyone who sees them dies
within seconds.
The effect is nearly instantaneous.
Much like the mythical basilisk, the gaze
of SCP-4205 is deadly and inescapable.
The eyes only seem to appear to people who
are alone in a room, and never in places where
there’s more than one person.
But aside from that, there is no way to predict
where the eyes will appear.
Since it is unknown if the eyes are part of
a corporeal body, or even present on this
plane of reality, there is no way to contain
them or stop them from killing.
This brings us back to that fateful day, December
11, 1992.
The day that the SCP Foundation would finally
be given some tangible information on the
mysterious amber eyes, at the cost of one
of their researcher’s lives.
Wade Dalitz, a young man fresh out of his
university studies, was brought onboard as
a Junior Researcher by Dr. Mark Forsyth, a
Senior Researcher.
Dr. Forsyth recruited Wade after giving a
guest lecture at his university and being
impressed by Wade’s keen observational skills,
thirst for knowledge of the unexplained, and
determination to understand that which seemed
to defy explanation.
After Wade graduated, he was recruited by
Dr. Forsyth, and given the position of Junior
Researcher at the SCP Foundation.
where he assisted Dr. Forsyth, now a site
supervisor, in his research.
After several months of working under Dr.
Forsyth with minimal responsibilities, Wade
was finally given the opportunity to write
his first SCP report... on SCP-4205.
Following some initial documented appearances
of 4205, Dr. Forsyth approved further research
into the anomaly, with Wade appointed as the
lead researcher on the subject.
According to Wade’s entry, he was responsible
for the discovery of SCP-4205 when he spotted
the anomaly in a window.
Though later reviews of security footage determined
that he was not the first person to observe
the eyes, he did claim to be the first to
observe them and live to tell the tale.
In his writing on the subject, Wade is puzzled
by the fact that he survived his encounter
with SCP-4205, and wonders what could have
set him apart from the others that fell victim
to its gaze.
He found himself frustrated as he documented
SCP-4205, his rough drafts of reports dissolving
into angry rants about his own incompetence.
Wade had difficulty adjusting to his new responsibilities,
especially with the added element of his assigned
subject’s mysterious and volatile nature.
In between his reports on SCP-4205, its previous
appearances, and its effects on its victims,
he wrote letters to his father, desperate
for reassurance that he was not messing everything
up.
Letters that would sadly go unsent.
In his coverage of SCP-4205, Wade made note
of a troubling recurring element in each victim’s
death.
When medical professionals attempted to revive
the victims, it was always noted that their
brain activity stopped much more quickly than
in cases of death by natural causes.
When examined, all aspects of the body aside
from the brain were completely unharmed.
The brain, however, showed massive nerve damage
in the amygdala, hippocampus, medial temporal
lobe, and occipital lobe.
The appearance of this brain trauma has been
compared to the effects of electrical shock
or a severe head injury.
In addition to Wade, six other people on record
encountered SCP-4205.
Every encounter ended the same way, with sudden
brain death and severe nerve damage immediately
after viewing the eyes in a reflective surface.
The first encounter occurred on January 5,
1990, when Deputy Liaison Gena viewed the
eyes in a reflective glass one-way window.
Security tape reveals that the eyes appeared
in the window eight minutes before the Deputy
Liaison spotted them.
As soon as he did, he fell from his chair
and immediately died.
Though the specifics varied from case to case,
the end result of every encounter was the
same, with none surviving long enough to relate
what they experienced.
Every encounter except Wade’s.
As he continued his documentation of SCP-4205,
Wade’s mental state quickly began to deteriorate.
The process of his mind coming apart, and
his thoughts giving way to confusion, fear,
and anger at his own survival, is documented
in his reports on the SCP.
He agonized over the question of why he was
able to survive gazing into the eyes of SCP-4205
when so many others had not?
The question consumed him until he was unable
to eat, sleep, or do anything but obsess over
the SCP he was tasked with researching.
As he became more agitated, he began to write
about the eyes appearing to him again.
On one occurrence, he attempted to touch them,
and described the sensation like touching
a balloon to your arm after it has been charged
with static electricity.
He continued to report seeing the eyes.
The worst was when trying to sleep, during
which he was overtaken by violent sleep paralysis
and plagued with visions of the amber eyes.
The only comfort Wade seemed to find was in
memories of his loved ones.
He wrote about his mother and his father,
even as their memories grew foggier to him.
He also mentioned a man by the name of Theodore
Quale, who he claimed was a researcher at
the Foundation.
Later fact checking determined that this was
not the case, and that Quale must have been
someone from Wade’s past.
He wrote about Quale wistfully, mournfully,
with words of love and loss, tormented by
the sense that he was losing his grip on reality
and everything he once held dear.
As Wade descended deeper into a hell inside
his own mind, he continued to mull over the
questions of SCP-4205.
Was there more to it than what was visible?
Did it have a body?
Why had he survived his encounter with it?
And what did it want from him?
He decided that those who had perished immediately
were the lucky ones.
They had escaped the torture that had overtaken
his life.
The eyes were everywhere now, watching him
even as he attempted to unlock their secrets
on a Foundation computer.
He spoke to the eyes at one point, but refused
to write down what they had said to him.
His last entry, his last thought, was a plea
for Theodore Quale’s embrace.
There is no more written about the research,
or about the eyes, only a simple, desperate
need for a comfort that is long lost.
Now is the part of our story where terror
meets tragedy.
Contrary to what Wade thought, and what was
recorded in his final computer entries, he
did not survive his brief brush with SCP-4205.
The truth is that he spotted the amber eyes
in the glass above his terminal monitor while
recording the entry, and died seconds later.
Though his death was swift, it felt agonizingly
slow, as revealed by his descent into panic
and paranoia recorded in his writings.
The entries recorded as a result of the connection
Wade and the computer, his physical contact
with it at the moment of exposure to SCP-4205’s
anomalous effects allowing the terminal to
archive his final thoughts before he succumbed
to the deadly nature of the eyes.
The entries were never physically typed, but
rather jumped from his dying mind into the
mainframe.
His entries, the echoes of a dying mind, offer
a glimpse into the way that SCP-4205 kills
its victims.
In the seconds leading up to death, the amber
eyes fast-forward a person’s mind, feeding
on the electrical impulses that it gives off
as it speeds through what seem to be days
of fear and of a loosening grip on reality.
The death may be swift, but the suffering
is long.
Wade left the foundation with a digital fingerprint,
an echo of the person he was at his core in
addition to his experiences with SCP-4205
itself.
Wade spent his final moments terrified for
his life, dreaming of a father that he missed
and a long-lost love from his college days.
His sacrifice must not be forgotten.
Because no one ever survives an encounter
with SCP-4205, his documented final moments
are the only first-hand account in existence.
Junior Researcher Wade Dalitz gave us a gift
in death.
He allowed the SCP Foundation a glimpse into
the true horror of the amber eyes, and a reminder
of what they are capable of stealing from
us.
So be careful of windows, mirrors, screens,
and all reflective surfaces.
When you look into them, you never know what
you might see looking back.
The year is 1941, and the world is gripped
by the most violent and widespread war in
history.
Millions march to war as bloody battles are
fought across the globe, horrendous atrocities
are carried out on groups of people, and parts
of London are bombed to rubble on a weekly
basis.
Considering it’s only been twenty years
since the last world war, it must seem to
the residents of the early 20th century that
the world is coming apart at the seams.
And amongst all this chaos, it’d be easy
not to notice a secluded manor house in the
English countryside disappearing without a
trace for eleven days, before suddenly returning
to our reality.
But thankfully, one organization makes it
its sole duty to notice the unnoticeable and
understand the impossible - The SCP Foundation.
And within that anomalous manor house, Foundation
agents and researchers were about to find
horrors beyond even their darkest imaginations.
This is the grim tale of SCP - 1461, better
known as…
The House of the Worm.
When the manor house reappeared after its
eleven day absence, the Foundation zeroed
in, sending agents inside to investigate.
It was a two-level dwelling complete with
twelve bedrooms, four baths, three studies,
a main foyer slash ballroom, a library, a
kitchen, and a pantry-basement.
The Foundation observed that a number of these
rooms had been fitted with rows of bunk beds,
similar to a boarding house or barracks.
Only later would they understand why.
They found that the upper portion of the home
exhibited no abnormal qualities whatsoever,
but as the agents investigated further, they
found an entrance to the truly anomalous portion
of the manor - The extensive sub-level system.
No previous records of the building kept by
the local council indicated that there would
be anything below the manor’s basement - so
either the mysterious previous occupants,
who were nowhere to be found, had built this
sub-level, or it’d just appeared here on
its own.
Regardless of which was the case, agents and
researchers knew that whatever had happened
down here had everything to do with the manor’s
mysterious disappearance.
They descended into the depths of what seemed
like a man-made cave system, constructed primarily
from a mix of concrete, iron, and brass.
It was a behemoth of 20th century technology
- intricate, snaking systems of pipes, gears,
and pumping pistons.
It was like someone had built an entire factory
down here - but for what?
The agents began to spread out through the
labyrinthine bowels of the manor, hoping to
find some answers, but all they seemed to
discover was more questions.
This place hadn’t been built with any form
of comprehensible logic.
It was full of dead ends, stairways that ascended
and descended to nowhere, doors that would
open to reveal just walls behind them or not
open at all.
It was like a maze built by a maniac.
It didn’t help that it looked like the place
was recently hit by an earthquake with some
passages caved in and mangled machinery strewn
about.
It seemed that no human workers had interfered
with the impossibly complex and bizarre machinery
in quite some time.
A number of the materials used to construct
said machinery, as well as the gray sandstone
filling in the collapsed passageways, remain
unidentified to this day.
Already, the sub-level was proving to be a
complex puzzle box with only an estimated
75% of its layout ultimately being mapped
by Foundation researchers.
However, they would soon realize that this
place wasn’t just confusing - it was deadly.
The only method of self-maintenance detected
by the exploring agents were pipes that would
fire a thick, black lubricant onto the surrounding
machinery.
One of the Foundation agents had the misfortune
of getting covered in it while exploring a
darkened passageway, and eighty percent of
his body was melted as a result.
It appeared that the viscous, black goo was
incredibly corrosive to all organic matter.
A number of the machines also emitted dangerously
high quantities of gamma and X-ray radiation,
making it difficult to explore many of the
caverns without heavy hazmat protection.
And worst of all, were the extremely hostile
creatures living in the caves who would regularly
attack Foundation personnel.
These abominations came to be known as SCP
- 1461 - 1, vicious, steampunk Frankenstein
monsters - once human, but with large parts
of their bodies replaced by crude, mechanical
implants - including metal teeth and claws.
1461-1’s have displayed a taste for human
flesh, and they have dragged multiple Foundation
agents down into their lair to be “converted”
into monsters like them.
It’s believed that SCP-1461 is capable of
controlling these beasts through the strategic
use of sound from its brass speaking pipes,
leading them into areas where Foundation personnel
are present to instigate conflict.
Many of these pitiful creatures have had their
throats replaced by phonographs, endlessly
repeating the same nonsense phrases over and
over again:
“I am what you have made me.
I am choice and I am tyranny.
Forgive me.
I am then and I am now.
What gods they will be, then.
I am evil and I am flesh.
I am the trap.
I am the trapped.
I am beauty and I am chaos.
Children are selfish.
I am the worm.
I have broken God.”
Still, in spite of mazes, monsters, and deadly
chemicals, the agents persisted, and managed
to discover several important locations.
The Gel Production chamber on Sub-Level 3
creates glass jars from the unidentified sandstone,
and fills them with a slime that looks to
contain living eyes and teeth.
The Factory Deliveries room is filled with
a huge number of crates and boxes, which seem
to shift and change in number between Foundation
patrols.
The Speaking Tube Room on Sub-Level Eleven
contains a grand pulpit that acts as the connecting
point for the complex array of speaking tubes
running through the entire cave system.
The body parts of a deceased female also appear
to be wired into the machinery, like spare
parts.
And on Sub-Level Twelve, they found the so-called
Catalyst Room.
Here, they discovered a huge, complicated,
clockwork and steam-powered machine that appeared
to be broken and missing some parts.
Most horrifying of all though, is the raised
platform in the center of the Catalyst Room
on top of which is a metal hospital bed.
A desiccated male corpse rests upon this bed,
its chest punctured by large syringes connected
by tubes to some kind of pumping machine.
The parts connecting this pumping machine
to the overall apparatus of the room were
missing though, leaving its purpose a mystery.
The Foundation assumed that fluids used to
be drawn out of this corpse to somehow power
the machine.
You may be starting to worry that there don’t
seem to be any answers here, that this house
is one big mystery - but lucky for you, you’re
wrong.
An old journal was also discovered in the
Catalyst Room, and if what is written inside
is to be believed, then we may finally have
some truth about who created the House of
the Worm, why it was created, and what horrible
events triggered its mysterious disappearance
and reappearance.
His true name has been redacted by the Foundation
and special efforts have been made to maintain
secrecy around the House, seeing as it’s
an anomaly of great interest to a cult known
as the Church of the Broken God, so we’ll
just call the one who made this place “The
Inventor.”
Before any of this, the Inventor was one of
the many Englishmen traumatized and almost
killed in the horrific trench battles of World
War One.
After a near death experience, the Inventor,
like many geniuses and madmen, was plagued
by surreal and nightmarish visions.
He saw a huge creature that he referred to
as “The Worm” - a gigantic, metal monstrosity
with dragon-like jaws full of gnashing gears
that rampaged through Europe, destroying and
devouring everything in its path.
These apocalyptic visions also presented him
with a solution, vague blueprints for a machine
that might be the salvation of him and any
others willing to take his new gospel to heart.
An escape from a world that the Inventor knew
in his heart was about to end.
He hired work-starved labourers from across
the country to help him make his visions a
reality and began a massive, secret construction
project beneath his isolated country manor
house.
For The Inventor, it was all a labour of love.
He wanted to protect his wife, son, and daughter
from the terrible jaws of the Worm.
But as the project stretched on, his wife
began to suspect that he’d lost his mind.
Many of his workers, however, felt just the
opposite.
They became infatuated by the Inventor’s
sermons on the nature of the Worm and the
coming apocalypse they hoped to escape.
Soon enough, they had become a bonafide cult,
constructing the elaborate sublevels underneath
the house in preparation for the fast approaching
day of reckoning.
Then came World War Two.
The Inventor saw Hitler, hungry for war, as
one of the avatars of the Worm.
Finally, knowing the time was right, he activated
the machine, and successfully trapped the
Worm in the bowels of his mechanized home.
However, as the Blitz raged and London’s
bombing began, the Inventor felt as though
he hadn’t stopped anything.
He realized once and for all that he was never
meant to stop the apocalypse, only escape
it.
And by throwing the final switch and setting
the machine he and his followers had built
into overdrive, he did just that.
This was the moment the House of the Worm
disappeared, transporting the Inventor, his
family, and his devoted staff to a different
world.
An empty grey world, devoid of war, but also
lacking all the comforts of regular life,
including food.
Things went downhill from there, as their
supplies quickly began to run out, and the
cult descended into cannibalism in order to
survive.
Things weren’t going much better in the
Inventor’s personal life.
His wife, fearing what would happen to the
family, took her own life and the life of
his daughter.
Though by this point, the Inventor’s mind
was so fractured that it’s possible he may
have killed them himself.
Either way, it was only the Inventor and his
son left, and more trouble was brewing.
Eudora, one of the staff trapped in the building
with the Inventor and his cult, started a
mutiny.
She claimed the Worm spoke to her from below,
and that their only path to salvation was
pleasing the Worm.
How would they please it?
A sacrifice, of course.
They would give it the son of the man who
had trapped it.
The mutineers took the Inventor’s only remaining
child, and descended into the lowest sub levels.
The Inventor followed, hoping to track them
down, save his son, and salvage something
from this nightmare.
As he ventured deeper, battling the members
of Eudora’s new cult, he found that they
were changing themselves, becoming the half-human
cyborg creatures that the Foundation would
later discover.
The Inventor would find Eudora herself in
the Speaking Tube Room.
Her body, still living, was wired into the
machinery, and she had sacrificed his son
to the Worm.
In a rage, the Inventor murdered Eudora, or
whatever was left of her, then heard a familiar
voice speaking out of a nearby speaking tube.
It said:
“I am what you have made me.
I am then and I am now.
I am choice and I am tyranny.
I am evil and I am flesh.
I am beauty and I am chaos.
I am the worm."
The voice was his own.
In that terrible moment, the Inventor realised
that the Worm wasn’t a giant, all-devouring
monster, it was him.
In trying to protect his loved ones from a
perceived apocalypse, he’d brought them
all to their horrible demise.
He’d trapped them with the monster he’d
hoped for them all to escape from, because
no matter what you build, you can’t escape
who you are.
Grief stricken and broken, the Inventor descended
into the Catalyst Room.
There was his son, stuck with the syringes,
drained of all life to fuel the mighty machine
his father created.
In his last moments, the Inventor decided
to do the only noble thing: He threw himself
into the machine, destroying both it and himself
in the process.
The house was transported back to our reality,
but the Worm, in a sense, was no more.
But who knows if the Worm is really dead.
Its thoughts and poisonous intent still lingers
in the caverns, and rattles through the speaking
pipes.
Whatever really happened, the Foundation is
still picking up the pieces today - and who
knows what lurks in the parts still hidden
from our knowledge.
We’ve all heard of the Led Zeppelin song
“Stairway to Heaven”, a title that invokes
the image of a stairway leading up to a land
of peace and paradise.
But where else could a stairway lead?
To a dusty attic full of old photo albums.
To the upper level of a mall, where the movie
theater and frozen yogurt shop are neatly
situated.
Perhaps it leads to a rooftop with a beautiful
view.
Or maybe, just maybe, a staircase could lead
you to SCP-2427.
SCP-2427, appropriately nicknamed “A Thing
Full of Stuff”, is an extradimensional area
filled with a variety of unusual and anomalous
objects.
SCP-2427 can be accessed by way of a broken
stone staircase located in rural Ohio.
According to local legend, carrying a sprig
of hemlock up the broken stairs will allow
a person to emerge into a mysterious grass
clearing that appears to be in a forest somewhere
in the United States.
No matter what time a person ascends the staircase,
the solar time in the clearing will always
be 2:00 PM.
You know how people say “it’s 5:00 somewhere?”
Well, it’s 2:00 somewhere too, and that
somewhere is here.
The pocket dimension that is SCP-2427 is thought
to have been a holding area for weapons, prisoners,
and artifacts belonging to an ancient cult
known as The Brazen Heart.
Little is known about this relatively obscure
cult, other than the fact that they worship
the demonic entity Moloch - a known enthusiast
of violent human sacrifice - and were previously
thought to have been eradicated during the
Spanish Inquisition.
The existence of SCP-2427 suggests that they
are very much not eradicated and are still
active.
They refer to these holding areas as “attics”
and though no confirmed members of the Brazen
Heart have been contacted, it is considered
possible that there are at least a handful
of other attics hidden around the world.
The Foundation has identified seven anomalous
objects inside of SCP-2427 so far, each strange
in its own beautiful, though often terrible,
way.
Like snowflakes, if they were capable of killing
or maiming you.
The first object in SCP-2427, aka SCP-2427-1,
is a seemingly normal fire hydrant.
However, if you think there’s anything normal
about the items found here then you haven’t
been paying attention.
The hydrant is made out of lead, and, when
opened, it expels high levels of ionized radiation.
No specific measurements of the radiation
have been taken yet, but it is definitely
hazardous to human health.
One unfortunate member of D-class personnel
has proven that it is a high enough level
to melt human flesh.
Sorry about your face, Dave.
The hydrant is currently contained within
an electrified perimeter and is not to be
opened under any circumstances to prevent
any further flesh melting.
The last thing we need is another Dave incident.
The second object contained within SCP-2427,
or SCP-2427-2, is not actually an object at
all, it’s a building.
Only on number two, and we’re already throwing
curveballs at you.
Trust no one, surprises lurk around every
corner.
This particular building resembles a large,
multi-storied sanitarium built in the 1860s.
Though it is clear from the outside that the
building has, or should have, multiple stories,
the inside is a different matter.
Past the building’s front doors is a non-Euclidian
space consisting of a single floor and three
sparsely decorated rooms with one central
foyer.
The first room is the holding place for SCP-2427-3,
the second contains SCP-2427-4, and the third
room contains nothing except scattered religious
documents, bottled water, and a selection
of canned foods.
No unauthorized staff are permitted to enter
the building, in order to minimize complications
or potential employee casualties.
The first two anomalies on this list are hardly
even strange by SCP Foundation standards.
Sure, the hydrant can melt your face and the
building defies the laws of physics and space,
but that’s just a regular Tuesday around
these parts.
been there, seen that.
What else have you got?
Well, SCP-2427-3 is where things really get
strange.
If you’re wandering through the bowels of
SCP-2427-2 and you make a wrong turn into
the first room, you will find yourself face
to face with a startling sight.
This entity is a combination of electronic
circuitry, a cow’s digestive tract, the
hairless head of a human man, a hat rack,
several lengths of garden hose, and an unidentified
crystalline structure.
This creature is extraordinarily fast and
strong, exhibiting carnivorous tendencies
and a very strong point of view on the world
around it.
Lucky for us, it is capable of speech and
is able to tell us just what it thinks.
Though this monstrosity doesn’t have much
of a right to pass judgment on anyone, cow
intestine body and all, it has expressed a
violent hatred of all life that it considers
“impure”.
Anyone who encounters SCP-2427-3 experiences
an overwhelming desire to submit themselves
for judgment, allowing the creature to determine
their “purity”.
There is a rumor that, if one is judged to
be “pure”, they will have a wish granted.
If they are deemed impure, however, they will
be devoured alive.
If you’re tempted to introduce yourself
to the creature, your odds are not especially
great.
The creature has not encountered a single
“pure” being yet.
In order to protect the Foundation staff working
in its vicinity, the entrance to SCP-2427-3’s
room has been sealed off with a reinforced
steel door, and the windows have been paved
over with concrete.
Armed guards are watching the entrance at
all times.
The creature must be fed one live goat per
day, in order to keep its appetite sated.
The Foundation’s goat budget is through
the roof these days, but it’s worth it to
keep the thing contained.
Better to spend money on goats now and not
spend money on cannibalized personnel later.
SCP-2427-4 consists, not of an object located
within a room, but the room itself.
The room, which contains no furniture and
a linoleum floor, has a peculiar effect on
the human psyche.
Once a person steps foot into the room, they
lose consciousness for five minutes.
During this time, they will speak freely,
listing off a variety of negative qualities
about themselves.
Once they wake up, they have no memory of
entering this state, or anything that they
said during it.
It’s cheaper than therapy, right?
But it’s also much weirder, and less effective,
so you get what you pay for in the end.
A member of D-Class personnel who was observed
inside of the room waxed poetic about his
personal failings, beginning his monologue
with “my soul is a den of spiders” and
ending it with “O hearer, whence I awaken,
hesitate not to feed my flesh and my soul
to the Judge-beast.”
Somebody give this guy a hug.
Because the room seems to have no adverse
effects on human test subjects, except for
causing everyone who hears their monologue
a bit of discomfort, there are no containment
procedures in effect for it at this time.
We’ve had rooms, fire hydrants, and horrible
meat-robot hybrids, and now?
You can’t even trust the clouds in the sky.
SCP-2427-5 is a seemingly innocent cloud,
hovering stationary over the building.
When looked at by a human for more than three
seconds, the cloud will eject a ball of solid
lead toward the person at a supersonic speed.
That’s right, folks.
This cloud can and will shoot you.
It hates being observed, but it also hates
when you try to leave the perimeter.
It will attack any person attempting to leave
by firing the same lead ball at them.
So far, 14 personnel have been killed by this
highly aggressive cloud.
And some people still think thunderstorms
and hail are the worst things clouds have
to offer.
So naïve.
As it is a literal cloud, there is no way
to contain it, so no people in the vicinity
of the cloud are permitted to look at it for
more than three seconds at a time.
SCP-2427-6 is a series of 18 small trees,
spread throughout the instance of SCP-2427.
Above ground, the trees look normal, though
their species has proven surprisingly difficult
to determine.
From an external perspective, they are simply
ordinary trees.
However, radar analysis revealed that the
roots of these trees are deeply strange.
Instead of the usual twisting tree roots,
the ground below these trees contains a mass
in the shape of a human body.
Much to the disgust of the observing researchers,
these humanoid masses occasionally twitch
and move, as if alive.
The trees themselves appear to be growing
from the crotch area of each humanoid figure.
How’s that for morning wood?
This arrangement between tree and person seems
to be some kind of punishment, as each tree
is marked with a plaque reading: “The lecherous
suffer what they must and it is beautiful.”
Until it can be certain that the condition
of these human roots is not contagious, these
trees are to be treated as potential biohazards
and isolated in individual containers.
The final object in SCP-2427 currently categorized
by the Foundation is SCP-2427-7.
SCP-2427-7 is a pile of ashes and wood located
just behind a posted sign that reads: “The
Liars’ Cradle.”
Extensive testing has established that the
Liars’ Cradle was almost certainly used
as a torture device in interrogations performed
by The Brazen Heart.
A person standing within the boundaries of
the cradle, which encompasses the aforementioned
circle of wood and ashes, is unable to lie
without suffering the consequences.
Namely, they will be set on fire.
The nature of how exactly the Liars’ Cradle
works is not certain, and more research needs
to be done on it.
However, this much is known for sure: it contains
no sentient intelligence, it is not aware
of what it is doing.
It does not kill its victims, rather it keeps
them miraculously alive as it sets them on
fire, prolonging their agony and allowing
their interrogators to get the truth out of
them.
A series of experiments revealed that it only
immolates a person who is knowingly lying.
D-Class personnel given demonstrably false
information to repeat in the Cradle without
knowledge of its falsehood were not set on
fire.
However, when those same D-Class personnel
knowingly lied in the boundaries, they immediately
were set ablaze.
It is almost certain that the Brazen Heart
cult used the cradle as a method of interrogating
presumed liars in their midst.
Further investigation will likely reveal human
remains beneath the Cradle itself, though
this is just a hypothesis currently.
But come on, there has to be some bones somewhere
beneath something as ominous as The Liars’
Cradle.
Though they have only identified seven anomalies
inside SCP-2427 at the moment, there are plenty
more lurking in there waiting to be discovered.
In the foyer of SCP-2427-2, the Foundation
discovered an extremely ominous list of items,
clearly belonging to members of the cult of
the Brazen Heart.
This list included some familiar items, such
as “pilgrim provisions” also known as
the canned beans and soups found in SCP-2427-2,
a Level Three Purity Proctor, a Purge Engine
- disguised as a fire hydrant - and the Liars’
Cradle.
However, it also contained many things that
have not yet been discovered, such as One
Slaughtering Perseverance, 27 Pyre Children,
Three Ascended Cultivars, Seven Supreme Angelics,
Nine Dragons, and the Brazen Heart itself.
Dr. Gordon MacElroy, Site Director of Area-2427,
put out a memo to all Level 4 and higher staff
assigned to the area after the discovery of
this list.
Understandably, he was most concerned about
the “supreme angelics” and the “dragons”,
particularly the latter.
The cult, as most cults are, is fond of deliberately
obscure language, but you don’t want to
rule out the possibility they’ve got a fire-breathing
lizard or two stashed away.
In the meantime, as the Foundation is working
to better understand the contents of SCP-2427,
the area has been sealed off to the public.
A 500m perimeter has been established around
its entrance, and a fake private country club
has been set up as a front.
It’s only a matter of time before the rest
of the anomalies on the list are discovered,
and this Thing Full of Stuff gets even fuller,
of even more stuff.
Let’s just hope none of it ever gets out.
Because if there are more of these attics
out there, who knows what else the Brazen
Heart is hiding?
Their little cult may not be as extinct as
we thought...
You’re right in the middle of one of the
hottest summers on record.
The days are filled with bright, scorching
sun and searing heat., and you’ve been laying
around with your air conditioning on full
blast just to try and cool yourself off.
Sadly, it’s not really working, and the
heat is becoming way too much.
But then you remember, there’s this married
couple that lives near you, with no kids,
and they happen to have a swimming pool in
their yard.
Normally they keep to themselves, they’d
never let you use their pool, but they’ve
gone out of town for a few days.
Besides, the heat is killing you, you’re
sure that the neighbors wouldn’t mind if
you just took a quick dip, as long as you
clean up after yourself.
They probably wouldn’t even notice you were
ever there.
Cautiously, you make your way to their house.
It’s an unremarkable place, similar to most
of the other houses in this suburb of New
Mexico.
After checking that there’s nobody else
around, you climb the two-meter high cinder
block wall that stands around the back garden.
As you drop to your feet, sweaty and panting
from the unrelenting summer heat, you see
it: the pool, your salvation.
Water never looked so appealing.
Immediately, you step barefoot across the
sun-scorched tiles and sit on the edge, legs
in the water.
It’s cool and refreshing, perfect for a
day as hot as today.
You’re already changed and wearing your
swim trunks, so it doesn’t take long for
you to paddle out to the middle of the pool,
letting that chilled, clean water cool you
off.
As you’re taking a dip, you notice the pool’s
jets turning on automatically.
It’s a little bit odd, but you shrug it
off.
That couple clearly shelled out for a pool
with a lot of fancy bells and whistles.
But extra features aren’t why you’re here,
you came because if you didn’t, then you
could have melted under all that sunlight.
Floating on the surface of the water, you
relax with your arms behind your head and
close your eyes.
You don’t have time to realize that coming
here was a mistake.
Instead, you start to feel relaxed.
So calm, so tranquil.
You’re one with the water around you now.
It’s almost as though you could just disappear…
So, you do.
The police never find any trace of you, everyone
else simply writes it off as a random disappearance.
There’s not even so much as a scrap of your
body left in the pool, just the clear, clean
water.
Why?
Because the swimming pool you decided to take
a cooling dip in wasn’t an ordinary pool.
It was SCP-242.
But don’t worry, you won’t be the last
to make that costly mistake.
What you didn’t know is that the “married
couple” who live in that house are secretly
a pair of SCP Foundation doctors.
The house isn’t even theirs, the Foundation
procured it after the former owner, a retired
out-of-state landlord, strangely vanished.
He had been struggling to find anyone to rent
the place, so eventually decided to give up
on the property game and move in there himself.
After three days, he was never seen again.
Now, that house has only one rule that must
be followed above all else: do not swim in
the pool.
SCP-242 is, at least to the untrained eye,
just an average swimming pool.
A decent nine meters in length, four and a
half wide, and it holds around 53,000 liters
of sterile pool water.
Like we mentioned before, it’s even got
some nifty features like water jets, a dual
waterfall, and a built-in vacuum unit for
sucking out any impurities.
And we mean any impurities.
You see, SCP-242 does go by another name:
the Self Cleaning Swimming Pool.
And while that might not sound as foreboding
or dramatic as “The Scarlet King” or “The
Wendigo Skull” or “The Horrifying Nasty-Dude
of Ultimate Badness” - okay, we made that
last one up - we can assure you that you don’t
ever want to suffer the fate of taking a swim
in this pool.
There was an incident a while ago, recorded
by the Foundation through a secret hidden
camera.
The house where SCP-242 can be found had been
left vacant for a time, and once again some
opportunists decided to take advantage of
the empty swimming pool.
This time it was a couple, a man and a woman
in their early twenties.
They climbed up the back wall, undressed,
and even stole a couple of plastic inflatable
rafts from a shed in the house’s backyard.
The water jets switched themselves on, startling
the girl, but her boyfriend told her not to
worry, the filter to clean the pool was probably
just on an automatic timer, right?
Surely it wouldn’t have been anything to
worry about.
After swimming around together for about twenty
four minutes, the couple both agreed that
the water felt warm, tingly even.
Both of them climbed onto their rafts, eventually
falling asleep while still holding each other’s
hands.
But, almost half an hour after the jets had
started, something caused the two rafts to
burst.
The couple awoke, startled by the loud pop
of the splitting inflatables and being plunged
back into the water.
The pool around them immediately began frothing
violently, deep red streams of blood swirling
through the water as the couple screamed in
fear and agony.
Both of them tried to desperately swim to
the edge, hoping to leave the pool and get
to safety.
But unfortunately, that plan didn’t work.
Before they could reach the edge, the man
and the woman were pulled under the surface
of the raging water, their limbs thrashing
as they still tried in vain to escape.
Eventually, they vanished under the crimson,
bloody water.
The frothing slowly began to calm, and the
red in the pool dissipated, once again becoming
clear after forty-eight seconds.
The couple were never seen again, and a cover
story was leaked to the press by the SCP Foundation
two weeks after they went missing.
According to them, the pair had eloped together
somewhere in Mexico.
If only, that sounds a lot nicer than what
actually happened to them.
So, this swimming pool clearly has some anomalous
properties, that much is obvious.
But what exactly are those properties, how
exactly does SCP-242 work?
Is it an interdimensional gateway that drags
people to a nasty alternate universe if they
spend too long swimming in it?
Or is the swimming pool itself a sentient,
carnivorous creature that lures humans in
only to devour them?
Maybe the water is teeming with invisible,
flesh-eating piranhas that can strip the meat
from a bone in a matter of seconds.
Well, good guesses all around but actually,
it’s none of these.
It’s unclear what causes the pool’s anomalous
effects, it could be a property that is completely
unique to the water contained in SCP-242.
Or maybe it’s down to the exact shape and
measurements of the pool itself.
It could even be a combination of both.
But whatever the cause, the result is always
the same.
When any object, substance, or even living
organism is placed in SCP-242, it will be
entirely rewritten on a molecular level.
The genetic and atomic structure will fall
apart, and the subject will be transmuted
into sterile water.
In fact, not just clean water, but water that
remains sterile even when removed from the
pool.
If you took a cup of SCP-242’s water and
mixed something like food coloring into it,
the food coloring would not be absorbed into
the water, instead staying as one non-miscible
bubble.
This process doesn’t happen instantly though,
it can vary depending on how contaminated
or complex the substance placed in SCP-242
is.
For example, water sampled from a nearby river
was sterilized and purified by the pool in
about seven minutes.
A sample of stagnant pond water, riddled with
various diseases and germs, took eleven minutes
longer.
What about fifty thousand liters of coal tar?
Well, that one took a little longer, twelve
long days to be exact, but was still turned
into pure, sterile water.
And as for a living human being?
Maybe ask that couple that took a dip in the
Self Cleaning Pool.
The Foundation is naturally fascinated with
the pool, and after extensive examination,
they have determined that SCP-242 doesn’t
seem to have been intentionally designed for
the specific anomalous function it performs.
The components of SCP-242 beyond the pool
itself; the filter, the vacuum, the pipes,
none of these parts nor anything about the
swimming pool’s design appear to be responsible
for disintegrating matter until only water
remains.
You might have noticed that in the case of
the ill-fated couple who took a swim in SCP-242,
the water jets and waterfall features switched
themselves on automatically, before the pair’s
grim demise.
Somehow, these features are able to activate
without the need for electricity, as disconnecting
the pool from a power source will not stop
the jets and waterfall from coming on once
a non-water substance is placed into SCP-242.
The same goes for the pool vacuum, which apparently
cannot be jammed or malfunction.
Even when the bottom of the pool is awash
with viscous liquids like that coal tar, the
vacuum will continue to operate as normal,
scrubbing away at the floor of SCP-242.
The one part of the Self Cleaning Pool that
doesn’t work as you would expect is the
water filtration system.
There is never any water being cycled into
the pool, nor out of it.
As a matter of fact, the pipes connected to
the filtration system have all been removed.
Then again, who needs a filtration system
when your backyard swimming pool can just
spontaneously reduce anything to clean water?
But that raises another frightening thought:
Everything that the pool has ever taken and
converted is still in there - animals, objects,
people - just swimming around you.
Perhaps, if they could still think, they’d
scream and shout and tell you to get away.
To run while you still can.
But the second your skin touches the water,
you’re destined to be with them.
Forever and ever and ever.
It’s enough to send a liquid chill down
your spine.
Okay, so if it’s not the actual physical
pool that causes these anomalous effects,
that must mean it’s something in the water,
right?
Perhaps some microscopic, flesh-devouring
microbe, or some ancient curse that was placed
on the water before it was used to fill the
pool?
Surely, if you took a cup of the water out
of SCP-242, it would still break down structures
on a molecular level, leaving only more sterile
water.
Well, the researchers working at the SCP Foundation
thought much the same and conducted a series
of tests to determine the exact properties
of SCP-242’s water.
One test involved submerging two D Class test
subjects, each wearing an atmospheric dive
suit, into SCP-242.
The goal was to determine if it was safe to
consume the water from SCP-242 while both
inside and outside of the pool.
Test Subject A was lowered into the water
and instructed to drink from a metal straw
by their mouth.
The eyepieces of their goggles were blacked
out, so they couldn’t see what they were
drinking from.
Subject B filled a barrel with the same water
from SCP-242, and then was made to put on
an atmospheric dive suit, but instructed to
stay out of the pool.
Test Subject A was told to drink directly
from the pool, remarking that the water was
warm, and had a bit of a noticeable chemical
aftertaste, but was otherwise normal.
Then, Test Subject B drank some of the same
water from the barrel.
Apparently, it was cool, and tasted of…
well, nothing, just like water usually does.
After a moment more of drink, Subject A began
belching, finding they had uncontrollable
gas.
The water had begun to feel warmer, stinging
the subject’s mouth while, for Subject B,
the water from the barrel stayed cool and
refreshing.
The Foundation doctors overseeing the experiment
instructed Test Subject A to keep drinking,
which they did until it felt even hotter to
the taste.
One of the D Class’s fillings even fell
out, and eventually, the structural integrity
of Subject A’s dive suit failed, presumably
disintegrated by the water from SCP-242.
After a few muffled screams and gurgling noises,
Test Subject A wasn’t heard from again,
and we can all probably guess why.
As for Subject B, they kept drinking from
the barrel, suffering no adverse effects,
even after seventeen long hours.
There were no noticeable psychological or
physical changes, even their urine showed
no traces of abnormality.
The water from SCP-242 left in the barrel
evaporated as normal, leaving behind no residue
or any indicator as to why taking the water
out of the pool made it safer to drink than
the same water in the pool.
Perhaps the moral of the story is to just
be careful where you choose to take a swim,
otherwise, it could be your last.
You’re on a road trip - the kind that stretches
over days on end, and you need to make multiple
stops along the way to refuel the car and
yourself.
The last time you remember stopping to get
more gas and a bite to eat was back in Wyoming,
and now, you’re in the heart of Montana.
Thankfully, like an oasis in the desert, you
see the town of Clear Water off in the distance.
It’s a vibrant, welcoming little place,
a perfect slice of classic, small-town Americana.
You took a similar trip last year, and vaguely
remembered stopping at Clear Water that time
too and you’re glad to be back.
In particular, you remember the Old Prairie
Diner, a folksy little place with the most
delicious Huckleberry Pie you ever tasted.
Perhaps it’s about time for you to give
it another try.
You fill up your tank and stop at the diner.
The food tastes just as good as you remember,
but one thing is off: The entire staff seems
to have changed.
It’s the exact same diner you ate in a year
ago, no doubt about that, but it looks like
everyone from the wait staff to the cashier
to the cooks have all been replaced.
You try your best not to think about it, after
all, businesses are allowed to replace their
staff, but the longer you sit in the diner,
the more uncomfortable the feelings become.
You need to ask someone, just to push away
the fears that you’re going crazy.
When a waiter passes by, you compliment the
food, and mention that you ate here last year
too.
You ask the unfamiliar waiter if they had
worked here back then.
They confirm that, yes, they’ve always worked
here - and so has everybody else.
The diner is a family business.
You leave town not too long after that, feeling
vaguely unsettled, and as a voice on the radio
warns about the incoming rain, you tell yourself
that you never want to return to the town
of Clear Water, Montana.
As you leave, the memory of the town seems
to fade from your mind in real time, but little
do you know, the people of Clear Water will
never be able to leave.
Ever.
It’s because something horrifying will happen
in Clear Water every single year, and that
thing is known to the SCP Foundation as SCP-3300.
This annual anomalous event is Clear Water’s
own local curse, always occurring around mid-June.
While many of the mechanics of this event
still elude the Foundation’s understanding,
the outcome is well-documented: Every single
inhabitant of the town is replaced by a person
who didn’t previously exist.
While some elements may carry over from their
original counterparts, every person involved
will simply be a whole new person, with no
memories of the change or who they once were.
The process known as SCP-3300 lasts between
six and eighteen days, and once the process
has begun, it’s impossible for any outsiders
to intervene.
It begins with rain - a light, dreary drizzle
at first, but each day, the rain gets worse.
Soon, it’s a storm, and then, a maelstrom.
Flooding, hurricanes, tornadoes, all centered
around Clear Water, but cutting off neatly
just beyond it.
What happens in Clear Water remains in Clear
Water, and when the process has concluded
and the sun shines once more, everybody has
been changed .
Whenever the Foundation has tried to send
personnel or equipment into Clear Water during
SCP-3300, one of two things have happened:
In the more favorable scenarios, those attempting
to enter Clear Water have simply appeared
on the other side of the city limits.
In the less positive instances, personnel
and equipment have been lost forever within.
There is no stopping or even understanding
SCP-3300.
According to Foundation records, Clear Water
has been around at least as long as the Foundation
itself, perhaps even longer.
Clear Water has been able to undergo its yearly
nightmare without intrusion due to a unique
cognitohazardous effect, which creates a kind
of mental block around memories of the town
for outsiders.
You won’t forget Clear Water, per se, but
you will find it increasingly hard to focus
on.
Like something you can only ever see out of
the corner of your eye.
There is no saving the people of Clear Water.
The horror will play out again and again and
again…
The Foundation has no first-hand knowledge
of what happens in Clear Water during those
horrifying eighteen days.
But one account they have hints at a terrifying
possibility.
During an excursion into Clear Water, the
Foundation managed to collect a diary belonging
to a woman named Margaret Lane.
To the best of our knowledge, Margaret Lane
no longer exists, but if the contents of her
diary are to be believed, then what goes on
in Clear Water during SCP-3300 is far worse
than we’d ever imagined.
Margaret first started her diary not long
before SCP-3300’s 1995 iteration began.
She was in the middle of a tumultuous time
in her life - freshly clean from alcohol and
drug addiction, forced to live with her antagonistic
mother, and having peculiar and distressing
dreams.
In the first dream Margaret recorded, she
was...someone else, a woman living in a small
hut perhaps a century ago or more.
It was plague time.
She was looking down upon her daughter, bedridden,
her skin covered in painful-looking red blotches.
Her husband was already dead.
That’s when another man enters, a healthy
man.
He tells her that he’s found their salvation.
And then the dream ended.
Margaret woke up to a gray, dreary day.
There were clouds on the horizon.
The rain was coming.
It drizzled for the next few days, before
getting more intense - as one would expect
from an SCP-3300 cycle.
Of course, nothing seemed out of place to
Margaret.
Life carried on - she continued to stay clean,
resisting the offers of her old dealer, though
her relationship with her mother remained
frosty.
The rain started to get worse as voices on
the radio insisted that conditions would continue
to become more severe over the next few days.
They tried their best to maintain normality;
Margaret invited some friends - Jared, Sam,
Mike, and Isabel - to come over and play D&D
at her place.
That was when all hell broke loose.
While the group roleplayed, there was a furious
banging at the door, like whoever was knocking
was trying to bash the door down.
When Margaret’s mom opened the door to investigate
the commotion, she saw that an entire family
was standing there - a father, a mother, and
two young children.
The father immediately began furiously asking
why all these strangers were in his house.
When Margaret’s mother tried to tell him
that this wasn’t his house, he became increasingly
agitated, and walked straight into the home.
Margaret’s friends attempted to subdue him,
but he threw them off, displaying a supernatural
strength.
Margaret’s mom ran in with a golf club and
struck the mysterious man in the chest.
There was a nasty splat, but he didn’t seem
to react.
The golf club was just embedded in his chest,
having broken the skin and sunken in.
But there was no blood.
Just dripping water.
The father then pulled the golf club out of
his chest, and began beating Margaret’s
mother to death with it, all the while repeating
“My house” again and again, while his
wife and children watched with broad, sunny
smiles in the rain.
Somehow, Margaret knew that her mother was
beyond saving, and that there was no way of
defeating these things in a physical confrontation.
All they could do was run out to Jared’s
van with the rest of the group and high tail
it to the police station.
But when they arrived at the station, the
doors were barred and it appeared empty.
As the torrential rain hammered down from
above, there was nothing left to do but drive
out of town and try to escape whatever madness
was going on here.
But that was easier said than done.
They drove for what seemed like hours on end
as the rain and the howling wind persisted.
Jared had been injured during the fight with
the strange family and his health deteriorated
further as the drive stretched on.
They should have left the town of Clear Water
a long time ago, but it seemed like they were
nowhere.
It wasn’t long before Jared was lying dead
in the back of the van, and now, there were
only four of them left.
They kept driving - afraid, grieving, hungry,
and tired - and Margaret took the opportunity
to sleep.
It was no time to rest, but she was so exhausted
that she had no choice.
Margaret had a continuation of her earlier
dream.
The different her, the dream her, was laying
the plague-ridden body of her daughter in
the river.
But she wasn’t the only one.
All the villages of her settlement were placing
the bodies of their dead in the river, as
the water washed around them and through them.
The bodies became one with the water, and
then, they became the water.
The water was everything.
When Margaret awoke, it was to the horrible
sounds of bubbling and boiling.
That’s when she saw that Jared’s body
was...dissolving.
No, not dissolving, evaporating.
It was bubbling and convulsing, like it was
made of water, until the entire thing burst
into a cascade of hot steam.
After that, Margaret and the others left the
vehicle and refused to get back inside.
Nothing was making sense.
It was like something out of a nightmare.
As they walked, the rain hammered down upon
them.
They couldn’t have been walking for more
than a mile when they crashed into something.
It was a sign - “Welcome to Clear Water.”
It was like the town itself had drawn them
back.
Mike refused to return to the town of his
own free will, and began walking in the other
direction.
Moments later, he was walking back towards
them in silence, though he’d never intended
to.
SCP-3300 had distorted his path, and brought
him back.
It was clear that Mike was shaken to the core
by the experience, but they had to press on.
They would head to the grocery store for food
and then to a sporting goods store where they
could hopefully grab some guns to fight the
violent, altered people who’d somehow appeared
with the rain.
But things didn’t go to plan - or what little
plan there even was.
Mike shot himself on the first night at Dirk’s
Sporting Goods, leaving only Margaret, Sam,
and Isabel alive.
Perhaps one of the most terrifying details
of Mike’s death was the fact he didn’t
even bleed, instead, the gaping exit wound
in the back of his head was just full of water.
Water was all that seemed to be left of them.
Sam, seemingly driven to the edge by the sight
of Mike’s death, grabbed a hunting knife
to perform an experiment.
She cut into her own skin, and was horrified
to see only water dripping out.
They’d all been “changed”, and they
didn’t know why.
That’s when the survivors noticed something
else: There were people standing outside in
the rain, hundreds of them.
Not a single one they could recognize, all
new people.
Waiting.
Sam said only one word, “Outside”, before
walking out of the hunting goods store and
disappearing into the crowd and the rain,
never to be seen again.
Margaret mused that perhaps, in the end, she
had the right idea.
To be taken, killed, erased, or changed would
be inevitable.
In the final entry in Margaret’s diary,
dreams blend with reality as her mind finally
gives out from the terror.
She realizes, in her final moments, that there
is no way out.
There is no escape.
There is only water.
Water is eternal.
The rain is eternal.
All will be changed.
And given the fact that no trace of Margaret
was ever found, save for her diary, all her
fears turned out to be right.
She was taken and replaced by SCP-3300, just
as will inevitably happen to all the current
citizens of Clear Water the next time SCP-3300
rolls around.
It will be as inevitable and as indifferent
to those it affects as tomorrow’s sunrise.
You cannot change the rain, but believe us,
in Clear Water, Montana, the rain can change
you.
“There’s a monster under my bed!”
Almost every parent has heard their kids make
the claim, and it’s usually nothing more
than some unusual shadows, or at worst a household
pest scurrying around.
Parents usually tell the child to go back
to sleep, or maybe try to dispel their fears
by shining a light under the bed.
It’s a childhood rite of passage, and one
that usually passes soon enough.
But for one young woman in Missouri, the monster
under her bed was very real - and very dangerous.
SCP-3887-A doesn’t seem like she belongs
in a containment facility.
She’s a twenty-four-year-old woman who lived
a quiet life in her hometown until things
went horribly wrong.
She doesn’t appear to possess any special
abilities and the Foundation is able to contain
her without any difficulty.
But wherever she goes, death and destruction
follow.
It’s not her doing, but there is something
out there that will not stand to see her hurt
in any way.
Her personal monster under the bed is very
protective.
Something another young woman found out the
hard way.
Incident 3887-A-1 occurred in 2014, when the
young woman was attending a party with her
girlfriend.
Her partner was berating and humiliating her
in front of the guests, which was apparently
not a rare occurrence in their relationship.
Suddenly, something manifested under a nearby
table and before she could react, her girlfriend
was brutally mauled by the unknown creature.
Her limbs were completely severed from her
body, and died at the scene.
An undercover SCP agent who was implanted
within the local authorities, made their way
to the scene as soon as possible and found
SCP-3887-A in a state of shock.
And who can blame her, after the encounter
she just had with what would come to be known
as SCP-3887-B.
While 3887-A is a normal human with no unusual
abilities or characteristics, 3887-B is anything
but.
Foundation scientists have described it as
a humanoid entity standing over seven feet
tall.
Its skin is greenish-grey, and it has two
long, sharp horns on its head.
Its head and neck are covered in thick black
hair, and its eyes are a striking yellow color.
Its mouth is full of sharp fangs similar to
that of a shark, and its elongated arms allow
it to move on all fours.
It has a long, hairless tail that resembles
a rat’s, and possesses both male and female
reproductive organs.
No one knows where it came from, but they
do have an idea why it’s sticking around.
SCP-3887-B seems to be bonded to SCP-3887-A,
and can appear in any darkened area within
a five-meter radius around her.
While its favorite location is under 3887-A’s
bed, which has since been brought to the facility,
it appears to be able to teleport wherever
she is, just as it did during the party when
it made its presence brutally clear.
It has odd eating patterns, and is able to
gain nourishment from practically any object,
whether it resembles what we would consider
food or not.
Its favorite treats for example?
SCP-3887-A’s socks.
But it does have one weakness that has been
useful in containing it - it can’t stand
the light.
And it doesn’t just hate it, when 3887-B
is exposed to bright light, it develops blisters
and wounds and flees to the nearest dark area.
SCP Foundation scientists are at a loss to
explain exactly what this creature is though,
and SCP-3887-B seems to be a chimera of multiple
animals with multiple types of DNA.
It possesses DNA similar to humans, but also
from a type of Oryx with similar horns, as
well as a rat with the same type of tail,
as well as a common cane toad.
And then there’s even some DNA that doesn’t
resemble any known creature in nature.
Studying it further has been trickier though,
because it seems to have the effect of disrupting
any electronic recording devices near it,
causing lasting damage if it’s in proximity
to them for too long.
There has been one bit of good news for SCP
Scientists though, because while it has shown
that it can be extremely violent, it has not
attacked Foundation officials…
Not yet at least.
Its good behavior may not have anything to
do with how it personally feels about Foundation
staff though, and is instead all thanks to
SCP-3887-A. 3887-A has been completely cooperative
since she was taken into custody by the Foundation.
She doesn’t perceive them as a threat, and
so far it seems like SCP-3887-B is following
her lead.
It has a strong emotional connection to the
young woman, and when they’re alone they
show affectionate behavior towards each other.
While the creature does not seem to like the
Foundation, it doesn’t seem like it wants
to become hostile - unless the Foundation
gives it a reason to.
When 3887-A was interviewed following the
tragic incident, by undercover Foundation
Agent Bellamy, she was panicked and terrified.
She admitted that her partner often treated
her badly, and believed that the creature
was trying to protect her.
She admitted that she had seen the creature
before, she even had a name for it, she called
her Grenda.
3887-A always thought she was crazy, now there
was proof though - she was not imagining the
monster under her bed.
Describing Grenda as her “boogeyman”,
the young woman talked about how she had known
the creature since she was a child.
She grew up in an old house in the country
that was full of strange sounds that made
it sound like something was in her room with
her, and sometimes she would even catch a
glimpse of what she thought was a monster
under her bed watching her.
She tried telling her parents but they thought
she was making the whole thing up, and even
she was forced to wonder if she was hallucinating
or had somehow imagined the whole thing.
But then when she was a teenager, all of her
doubts were put to bed.
One night 3887-A’s parents were loudly fighting,
a sadly not rare occurrence in their household,
and she locked herself in her room to get
away from them.
As she hid, Grenda emerged from under her
bed for the first time - and talked with her.
And she isn’t the only one that Grenda is
willing to speak with, she’s also sat down
for her own interviews with Foundation researchers.
Well the researcher sat down, while Grenda
remained under the bed.
Foundation Researcher Dr. Tanner interviewed
Grenda, who was cordial but guarded and remained
deeply protective of the girl under her protection.
She expressed feeling guilty for getting 3887-A
in trouble, but Dr. Tanner assured her that
3887-A was not being punished and was being
kept at the Foundation for her own safety.
He offered that they could keep Grenda safe
as well, but she responded that as long as
3887-A remained safe, then she would be as
well.
She explained that her kind fed on the anxiety
of children, which was why they lurked under
their beds.
She was apparently only supposed to remain
with this girl until she was ten or so, but
became attached and decided to stay with her
which was against the rules of her people
and as a result she had been exiled from her
home.
At this point, Grenda offered to show herself
to the researcher and began to emerge from
under the bed.
Unfortunately, as has become standard when
attempting to document SCP-3887-B, all of
the recording equipment malfunctioned and
was unable to record Grenda’s appearance.
The Foundation continued to have questions
about this pair and their strange relationship,
and interviewed SCP-3887-A again, this time
by a Dr. Garden.3887-A told Dr. Garden that
she had been sleeping well and had been spending
lots of time talking to the entity under her
bed.
That led Dr. Garden to bring up a theory about
how 3887-B had come to exist.
The young woman speculated that Grenda may
have been created from her fears.
One of her first memories of being scared
was when she went to an aquarium and a massive
bull shark came close to the glass where it
bared its rows and rows of shark teeth, the
exact same kind of teeth that Grenda possessed.
In fact all of the traits Grenda exhibited,
like her rat tail, seemed to connect to childhood
fears that she had experienced.
3887-A always felt alone as a little girl,
and she believed that she might have manifested
Grenda as a companion who was there exactly
when she needed her to be.
This raised the question of whether SCP-3887-B
really was the unnatural entity, or if SCP-3887-A
is the source of the entity’s existence.
The next interview with SCP-3887-B would raise
even more questions.
When Dr. Garden went to interview SCP-3887-B,
it was clear the entity was agitated.
Grenada became hostile as soon as Dr. Garden
entered the room, saying she was hungry and
didn’t want to answer questions.
When Dr. Garden said that 3887-A had provided
it with socks, the entity reacted with anger.
The socks were just a snack.
To live it needed fear.
3887-B fed off human emotions - specifically
paranoia and anxiety.
SCP-3887-A used to be full of them, but now
she was unusually calm in the facility and
it was having a bad effect on her companion.
When Dr. Garden promised to talk to supervisors,
the creature became more agitated - and reached
out from under the bed, grabbing Dr. Garden
and pulling her under the bed.
No one knew what would happen to Dr. Garden
under the bed and SCP-3887-A was quickly summoned
to try to calm her companion down, but when
she called for Grenda, there was no response.
It was feared that Dr. Garden had been lost
to the area under the bed that no one can
access, but then thirteen minutes later, the
doctor suddenly emerged from under the bed.
She was bruised, soaking wet, and missing
articles including shoes, socks, and her glasses.
Later Interviews with Dr. Garden would give
the best picture yet of where SCP-3887-B comes
from.
Dr. Garden described being pulled under the
bed, which then led somewhere else entirely.
She fell for fifteen seconds, still held by
SCP-3887-B, but when she landed she was alone
in a large cave made of black rock with purple
gems in the walls.
The cave contained a waterfall, a lake, and
what looked like SCP-3887’s secret home.
It was filled with pictures of the girl she
was bonded to, a violin, some stuffed animals
- and large piles of the girl’s socks.
SCP-3887-B was there in the cave with her
too, watching her.
She would catch glimpses of the creature - her
white fangs and her yellow eyes.
She was terrified and ran screaming, trying
to find any way out of there as the creature
pursued her.
She couldn’t evade her forever though, and
eventually Grenda grabbed Dr. Garden.
She was lifted into the air as Grenda bared
her shark like teeth, but instead of eating
her, the creature instead took off the doctor’s
socks, and thanked her before somehow sending
her back up into the darkness.
She then found herself back under the bed,
surrounded by worried SCP personnel.
Since then, SCP-3887-B has not brought anyone
else into its home, it seems feeding on Dr.
Garden’s fear was enough for the time being,
and the situation has remained stable since.
The SCP Foundation has been able to develop
relatively simple containment procedures for
the two entities that make up SCP-3887, as
neither is currently hostile.
The two are contained within a standard humanoid
containment cell with the bed at the center.
SCP-3887-A is given standard amenities, a
healthy diet including a vitamin for some
minor health issues, and her own control over
the lights in the cell.
She has requested and been given a gaming
system for entertainment and up-to-date entertainment
media but was denied access to the internet,
a pet cat, and access to the on-site recreation
areas due to the risk of SCP-3887-B getting
loose.
The facility does have plans in place in case
“Grenda” decides to become hostile again
though.
While SCP-3887-A normally maintains control
of the lights in her cell, the Foundation
has a fail-safe installed so they can turn
them up at any time.
Since SCP-3887-B reacts negatively to bright
light, the lights can be used as a security
system to send her retreating back under the
bed until she can be pacified through other
measures.
While neither of the SCP-3887 entities appears
to be seeking to escape, it is impossible
to predict where and how 3887-B would act
if 3887-A was free from her cell again, and
whether she would attempt to harm those she
perceives as a threat to 3887-A as she did
in the past.
So for now, the Foundation is focused on keeping
both of them pacified - which, in the case
of 3887-B, means a healthy supply of socks.
But there’s one other lingering question
the Foundation hasn’t solved.
SCP-3887-B referenced being exiled from its
kin for breaking the rules and was confined
to a cave.
That means there might be others like “Grenda”
out there - and they may be more aggressive
and less scrupulous than she is.
While no other specimens have been found,
the SCP Foundation will be keeping a careful
eye on any reports of monsters lurking under
children’s beds.
They might just be telling the truth.
Lots of people believe in the possibility
of “past lives”, the notion that the life
we are currently living is not our first.
Before you were the person you are now, sitting
at home and watching this video, maybe you
were a Medieval king, a Renaissance painter,
or an ancient Spartan warrior.
Past Life Regression is a controversial practice
that allows people to look back at their supposed
past lives, looking through the eyes of someone
in another lifetime.
It’s a nice idea, and there’s something
exciting about the possibility of reliving
the experiences of a person from the past.
And wouldn’t you know it, the SCP Foundation
just so happened to discover an artifact that
allows a person to experience another person’s
memories.
It is not past life regression, and you have
no control over whose life you are peeking
into, but it allows you to look at the world
through their eyes.
However, when you look through someone else’s
eyes, there’s always the possibility that
you will see something you didn’t want to.
Something troubling, frightening, even traumatic.
Or worse.
So you may not want to subject yourself to
SCP-1123, or, as it has been ominously nicknamed,
The Atrocity Skull.
SCP-1123 is an old human skull with no teeth
or lower jaw.
Across the forehead region of the skull, the
Khmer word for “remember” is written in
blood.
Testing of the skull and blood determined
it was from the 1970s, and that both the blood
and skull belonged to the same person.
The Atrocity Skull was discovered by a Colonel
in the Vietnamese People’s Army in the 1980s,
as part of a collection of human remains displayed
in a Cambodian museum.
Struck by the bloody writing, and the peculiar
feeling that the skull gave him, the Colonel
decided to send it to Hanoi for further investigation.
While in transit though, the skull was intercepted…
by the SCP Foundation.
Foundation Agents set a trap along the road,
blowing out the tires of the Colonel’s transportation.
The skull was taken and sent to a Foundation
facility, and the Colonel was given an amnestic
to remove all memory of the skull’s discovery.
The staff of the Cambodian museum received
a similar treatment.
All written mentions of the skull were erased,
and now outside of the Foundation’s archives,
there is no official record of the skull ever
having existed.
The bloody writing on the skull has faded
over time and from a distance is barely visible
at all.
The first SCP Foundation agent to study the
skull, an unknown researcher whose name has
since been scrubbed from the Foundation archives,
had a series of unusual experiences while
observing the skull.
He reported that the script was invisible
from five meters away.
As he approached it, he noted that the writing
became clearer with each meter he got closer
until at one meter away, the writing looked
fresh.
Unable to stop himself, he reached out to
touch it, and found that his fingers came
away slick and red.
Somehow, the bloody writing was still wet,
as if it had been drawn only moments before.
As soon as he touched the text, he began to
experience anomalous sensory phenomena.
The room filled with the smell of smoke, he
could hear the sound of heavy breathing, and
the pounding of a heartbeat.
There were thundering footsteps behind him,
and he turned to look, but found nothing there.
He jerked his hand back away from the skull,
recoiling at the sensation of ants crawling
over the back of his hand.
His eyes began to sting, as if filled with
ash, and he stumbled backward, only to fall
to the ground from a sudden stabbing sensation,
like a shard of glass piercing his shoe and
the sole of his foot.
The researcher was removed from the room and
examined by a physician, who found that none
of these sensations had accompanying physical
symptoms.
They were purely psychosomatic, so it seemed.
There was nothing in his eyes, no wound on
his foot.
Contact with the skull had caused him to experience
these physical stimuli, but it was all in
his head.
And this was far from the full extent of SCP-1123’s
impact on those who interacted with it.
After several weeks untouched, the skull was
examined by yet another Foundation researcher.
When she touched the surface of the skull
to lift it and take a closer look, she fell
into a dissociative fugue state - a kind of
distressing altered state of consciousness.
She became confused, disoriented, and wouldn’t
respond to her name.
The skull was removed from her grasp as soon
as she became unresponsive, but this did nothing
to return her to normal.
The accompanying researchers simply had to
observe her and wait for her to wake up.
Six hours later, when she finally did, she
recounted what she experienced after touching
the skull.
She claimed that she had seen the life of
another person in the time between touching
the skull and returning to consciousness.
She could recount details of this other person’s
life, describing places she had never been,
events she had never witnessed, and even speaking
a language she had previously demonstrated
no command of.
The other researchers determined that the
person described actually had existed, though
they had since passed away, and that all the
little details were too specific to be a simple
coincidence.
After this encounter with SCP-1123, several
other researchers experienced similarly traumatic
fugue states.
The Foundation was able to identify several
shared characteristics among those who touched
the skull and experienced the life of another
person.
All of the people whose memories were seen
by test subjects died before the subject was
born, were a victim of violence or imprisonment,
died in a tragic or violent way by murder,
starvation, or infection, and died as a result
of being targeted by a political movement.
These patterns led to the coining of the SCP’s
nickname, The Atrocity Skull.
It is a skull that forces those who touch
it to relive past atrocities.
In order to further understand the nature
of the skull’s effects on test subjects
and the nature of the lives it imprints on
them, a series of experiments were performed
by the Foundation.
Various people of differing cultural backgrounds
were exposed to the skull, in an attempt to
determine what correlation, if any, there
is between someone exposed to the skull and
the type of person whose memories they experience.
In the first experiment, a man of Irish and
French ancestry was told to touch the skull.
He immediately collapsed, and began to scream
in Armenian and resist any and all assistance
from Foundation officers.
When he returned to full consciousness, he
explained that he had taken on the memories
of an Armenian farmer who was burned alive
by the Ottoman army in 1915 during the Armenian
Genocide.
During a different experiment, a man with
Haitian ancestry touched the skull.
Just before touching it, he complained of
a chemical smell and a powerful itching sensation.
After he touched it, he began to violently
cough.
His fugue state lasted for 60 minutes, and
was characterized by confusion and a sudden
ability to speak Kurdish.
After waking up from the fugue state, the
man was able to describe the imprinted personality
of an 85 year victim of a mustard gas attack
in Iraq in 1989.
A third experiment involved a woman with Chinese
ancestry, who became unresponsive for over
two hours after touching the skull.
She was clearly distressed and began to loudly
weep as the time progressed.
Once the two hours were up, she was able to
give an interview where she described her
experience while in the fugue state.
She experienced the life of a young Ukrainian
girl who died in 1932 as a result of violence
at the hands of a Soviet brigade.
Several other experiments were also conducted,
producing similar results.
Each time, the subject would experience a
fugue state lasting from around an hour to
upwards of six hours.
The experiments allowed the Foundation to
determine some statistical patterns in the
personalities and memories experienced by
test subjects.
The more victims that can be attributed to
a historical event, the more likely it is
that a test subject will experience the memories
of someone killed in that event.
There is no apparent correlation between the
nationality of the test subject and the nationality
of the person whose memories they will live
through.
While there are no negative physical effects
on test subjects who have come into contact
with the skull, there is a notable psychological
impact which can be attributed to the traumatic
nature of the memories that they were exposed
to during the course of the experiment.
Subjects have demonstrated bouts of grief
and depression, as well as struggles with
survivor’s guilt.
Though they themselves did not survive the
events that they witnessed, they feel as though
they did.
In an attempt to alleviate these psychological
effects, the Foundation administered several
types of amnestics to test subjects.
However, these were not effective and in many
cases, they were actively harmful.
The SCP Foundation uses a variety of amnestic
compounds as a part of its work, but none
of them were effective in treating test subjects
who had been exposed to SCP 1123.
Class B Amnestics, or Regressive Retrograde,
remove the most recently formed memories from
a person’s mind.
When these were administered to SCP 1123 test
subjects, their own memories began to fade
away, while the memories of their imprinted
personality remained intact.
If the dosage was increased, only the memories
of the atrocity would remain.
Other amnestics with similar functions yielded
similar, and equally troubling results.
The wrong memories would disappear, and the
subject’s original personality would begin
to give way to that of the person the skull
had imprinted on them.
And so another type of amnestic was applied
in an attempt to solve this issue.
Class E amnestics, or Ennui, do not remove
memories from the subject’s mind, but rather
lessen the subject’s emotional response
to them.
They are intended to weaken neural pathways
and remove the emotional component from a
given memory, reducing the subject’s stress
or trauma response to the information of said
memory.
All of the science behind this class of amnestic
suggests that it would be beneficial to the
test subjects involved in this research, but
for some reason they were still ineffective.
The application of Class E amnestics to test
subjects following exposure to the Atrocity
Skull only worsened the subject’s trauma
response, contributing to panic attacks, flashbacks,
and other symptoms of severe Post-Traumatic
Stress Disorder.
Eventually, the use of amnestics to benefit
these test subjects was abandoned entirely.
Experimentation with the skull was placed
on hold until a beneficial treatment program
for the test subjects could be established.
Currently, to preserve the condition of the
skull and the writing on its surface, SCP-1123
is kept contained in a hermetically sealed
container in an argon gas atmosphere.
When it is removed from containment for experimentation
and testing, it is kept in light at no more
than 50 lux, with the temperature inside the
container kept between 20 and 24 degrees Celsius,
and 55% humidity.
No one is permitted to handle the skull under
any circumstances except for controlled experimentation.
There is a saying that says those who do not
learn from history are doomed to repeat it.
As distressing as the experience of touching
SCP-1123 may be, perhaps there is a use for
it.
Confronting historical atrocities directly,
and looking through the eyes of their victims,
is a stark reminder of all the evil that humanity
is capable of.
Certainly the history reflected by the Atrocity
Skull, imprinted directly into the minds of
all who touch it, will not be soon forgotten.
Those who have touched it, those who speak
to them, and all who learn about the impact
of the Atrocity Skull, should take care to
remember history.
To learn from it.
To make sure that these evils are never repeated
again.
Perhaps, we will even reach a point where
we do not have to look through the eyes of
the victims of institutionalized evil.
We will simply have moved beyond it.
Then, and only then, will it be time for the
skull to be destroyed.
Until then, it remains preserved in the halls
of the SCP Foundation as a reminder that,
amidst all of the horrors contained in those
walls, sometimes the greatest monster is us.
For a moment, we want you to cast your mind
back to your childhood.
A time when you weren’t as busy or burdened
with the pressures of life that come as you
grow up.
When you were carefree and had your whole
life ahead of you, nothing but potential and
opportunity.
A simpler time, when the highest award you
could achieve wasn’t a grade or a promotion,
but something as simple as your mom or dad
pinning a drawing you did to the door of the
refrigerator.
Oh, to be a kid again, right?
Then again, maybe returning to younger days
is better left as a fantasy.
It’s hard to imagine that something so pure,
so simple and wholesome as a drawing on the
fridge could ever be something dark, horrific
even.
But then, you learn about SCP-683, and all
of a sudden returning to your childhood becomes
something you hope never happens.
SCP-683 is an anomaly with various parts to
it, so we’ll start with SCP-683-1.
At first glance, it looks to be just an ordinary
refrigerator; to be more precise, it’s actually
a 1953 Crosley Shelvador, for any of you fridge
experts out there who are curious about the
exact make and model of SCP-683-1.
For everyone else, picture the refrigerator
that Indiana Jones hid inside to miraculously
survive a nuclear blast in Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull.
I don’t know about you guys, but I’m feeling
nervous already.
Like we said, at first glance you’d struggle
to spot anything out of the ordinary about
this particular fridge, apart from maybe some
slight wear and tear on the outside.
Inside though, it’s perfectly clean, kept
in perfect working condition for keeping food
cool.
But that’s the first weird thing about SCP-683-1.
You see, despite the Foundation conducting
tests to deliberately make it messier, the
fridge seems to have an inbuilt function that
you wouldn’t find in one from Home Depot.
It can self-clean.
Yes, that doesn’t sound all that impressive
- unless you’re a fridge owner yourself
and know what a nightmare they can be to keep
clean.
While it’s definitely weird, it’s not
the last of SCP-683-1’s anomalous properties.
The next is the fact that the power cord of
this refrigerator ends with a plug that doesn’t
match any known type of wall outlet.
Seems even stranger, after all, who would
design a fridge that can’t even be plugged
in, right?
In fact, the SCP Foundation had to design
their very own completely one of a kind adapter
to connect SCP-683-1 to an ordinary gas-powered
home generator.
Once plugged in though, SCP-683-1 functions
exactly like you would expect any other refrigerator
to… sort of.
It’s about time we move on to SCP-683’s
second component, designated as SCP-683-2.
Again, much like the fridge it is somehow
affixed to, at first look this part looks
completely ordinary.
It’s a drawing, created using felt pens
and pencils, presumably by a child between
the ages of five and seven years old.
There’s evidence of some moderate water
damage to the paper, but once again nothing
all that strange to look at.
Even the subject of this child’s drawing
is pretty mundane, just some scribbles of
a pleasant mountainous landscape, a house,
a well, a dog, a figure wearing a chef’s
toque and, of course, an anthropomorphic sun
with a smiley face.
Now sure, that might not sound all that impressive,
but we would advise not to say anything like
that out loud.
Criticizing the drawing is a comment you might
wish you hadn’t made, just like when you
fill our comment sections with dated Among
Us memes.
Any person that makes any kind of negative
or disparaging remark about the SCP-683-2
drawing, or tries to remove the paper from
the fridge door of SCP-683-1 will suffer a
grim, horrific fate.
The next time they try to eat anything, this
person will suffer immense, irreparable damage
to their internal organs, along with their
skin and muscle tissue.
This is intensely painful, causing the subject
agonizing pain as their organs and skin are
melted down.
The amount the person loses is equal to the
mass of food they’ve eaten; with each bite,
they will lose more and more of their body.
The painful process will not stop until they
have ingested 0.42 kilograms of food.
Making this even worse, the process doesn’t
seem to target any organs that would kill
the subject immediately.
They’re made to suffer in excruciating pain,
punished with torture for daring to try and
remove the drawing from the fridge.
Any and all subjects will die within twenty-six
days of taking that final bite and thus losing
the last piece of themselves.
But, where do the body parts of these people
go?
Surely, they don’t disappear, you must be
thinking.
And you’d be right.
In instances like this, the mystery third
component of SCP-683 is revealed.
Referred to as SCP-683-3, a brown paper lunch
bag will manifest inside the SCP-683-1 fridge,
containing a grim and grizzly assortment of
meals.
On every occasion, the bag contains a sandwich,
with a pretty disgusting filling: the flesh
and viscera of the last person who dared to
criticize the drawing on the refrigerator.
There is also a plastic ziploc bag, in which
you’ll find the other half of the stolen
organs and flesh of this unlucky person, along
with three chocolate chip cookies.
Surprisingly, these are actually completely
normal cookies with no traces of DNA or other
abnormalities to them.
Every time, there is also one final item that
forms the contents of SCP-683-3, and that’s
a note which reads “Be a good boy today”.
This note bears the same handwriting as appears
on the outer surface of the paper bag, upon
which a single name is written: Eric.
Now, for those of you in the know about the
various anomalies of the SCP Foundation, that
particular, unassuming name might sound very
familiar.
It was the same name mentioned by another
anomaly, known as SCP-066.
A brief bit of context for you, SCP-066 was
a living ball of yarn that displayed friendly
behavior towards Foundation staff.
However, during an experiment, a thread was
cut from SCP-066’s body.
This caused the yarn to transform into a ball
of meat, with a pair of functional eyes protruding
from it.
SCP-066 became hostile, constantly asking
for an ‘Eric’ whenever someone gets too
close to it.
The same name, Eric, was also found carved
into the back of SCP-168, another anomaly
encountered by the SCP Foundation.
SCP-168 was an anomalous calculator, which
actually possessed some level of sentience
and had the ability to communicate.
So, who is Eric?
Well, theories range far and wide, but there’s
no real definitive answer as to exactly who,
or what Eric might be.
Some claim he’s a reality-bending entity,
others posit he’s an SCP that the Foundation
just doesn’t know about yet.
Regardless, he’s connected to some intriguing
entities; a sentient calculator, a formerly
friendly ball of yarn, and a fridge with a
child’s drawing on it that can steal people’s
organs and put them in a lunch bag especially
for him.
It would seem that Eric is a child, maybe
a schoolboy, possibly even the one responsible
for the drawing on SCP-683.
This child could even potentially be anomalous
in nature.
Of course, this is all just rampant speculation
on our part, so it’s probably best to take
all of that with a grain of salt.
As we’ve said before, it’s just a theory
- an SCP Explained theory.
Eric might just remain one of the Foundation’s
many unanswered mysteries for years to come.
But if that answer doesn’t satisfy you,
then why don’t we go back to SCP-683.
Maybe something in the fridge’s origin will
give us a further clue to the mystery of who
Eric is.
The fridge was first discovered by the SCP
Foundation in the storage unit of a Washington
home, owned by a woman named Yolanda.
As coincidence would have it, Yolanda was
a collector of vintage home furnishings, including
refrigerators, which would probably explain
why she didn’t think to throw out such an
old model of fridge from the 1950s.
According to her, she found SCP-683 simply
left on a nearby street corner, with nobody
around that could have left it there, or anyone
that could have possibly been transporting
it to the local dump.
To give her a hand moving the fridge, Yolanda
enlisted the help of her nephew, who agreed
to step in and assist her in getting SCP-683
back to her house.
Unfortunately, though, the nephew passed away
only two weeks later, apparently due to medical
complications that came as the result of a
hernia according to his death certificate.
Could Yolanda’s nephew have been the mysterious
and elusive Eric?
Could something have happened to him after
his death that allowed him to become some
kind of anomaly?
Who’s to say, we can only guess and hope
that one day we might get a full answer.
As to why Yolanda never suffered the effects
of SCP-683, she never actually tried to take
the SCP-683-2 drawing down from the fridge.
When asked why, she simply replied “It’s
a nice little picture, isn't it?
Why take it down?”
Maybe, just maybe, it might have even reminded
her of her nephew.
It would have been a futile and foolish idea
for Yolanda to have even tried to remove the
drawing at any rate, as any who try will suffer
that painful and horrifying process of losing
their organs and having them appear in Eric’s
paper lunch bag.
Even fire can’t remove the drawing from
the fridge, at least not permanently, suggesting
that even the paper it is drawn on has its
own anomalous properties.
On three separate occasions, the SCP Foundation
has attempted to test this, setting SCP-683-2
on fire with nothing more than a match.
Every time, the drawing was incinerated, burned
to ashes until there was nothing left.
But, within sixty-eight hours, SCP-683-2 had
returned to its permanent fixture on the fridge
door, as if nothing had happened.
Interestingly though, the D Class members
of personnel that were instructed to burn
the drawing didn’t suffer the usual anomalous
effects of SCP-683.
A similar thing happens if multiple people
attempt to remove SCP-683-2 or say anything
negative towards the drawing.
In cases like this, only the very first person
who made a disparaging remark, or tried to
rip the drawing from the fridge will be the
one to suffer a long, painful torture by organ
removal, followed swiftly by death.
Now, if you cast your mind back to earlier
in the video, we told you that someone who
tries removing or disparages SCP-683-2 will
only suffer an anomalous lack of organs when
they next eat something.
So, you must be thinking that the way to avoid
that is to simply not eat, to fast, and not
ingest a single meal.
And yes, you’d be right, that does stave
off the anomalous effects of the fridge and
the drawing, but also means you’re heading
towards an even slower, painful death from
starvation.
To date, two different Foundation test subjects
have died this way by refusing to eat after
interacting with SCP-683.
True, the SCP Foundation is most likely sitting
on a whole cavalcade of different anomalies
that can keep a person alive without the need
for food, but you know what they’re like,
right?
The Foundation’s hardly likely to share
the keys to surviving without having to eat.
And there you have it, folks, that’s SCP-683.
Don’t worry, it’s highly unlikely that
you’ll ever encounter it.
The Foundation keeps it under lock and key,
in a cell fitted with a steel door and reinforced
hinges.
SCP-683 remains covered in a large cloth to
prevent any members of personnel from looking
at it when the fridge isn’t being used for
research or experiments.
But you have to wonder, what if it’s not
the only fridge with these anomalous properties?
After all, it’s rare for a manufacturer
to make just a single refrigerator of a certain
model.
Maybe you’d better be wary next time you
visit someone with an older model of fridge
in their kitchen, and just to be safe, if
there’s a drawing pinned to the front door,
leave it where it is.
Sometimes, dealing with anomalies that could
destroy the world with a flick of their wrist
can get a little old.
Sure, it definitely wouldn’t be a good thing
if the Devourer of Worlds...Well, devoured
the world, or if SCP-001 - When Day Breaks
- turned us all into weird, melty zombies.
But it’s almost impossible to conceive the
sheer scale of destruction that an XK-Class
End of the World Scenario would cause.
You’d be almost numb to it, if you even
survived.
In the words of SCP-2430 creator Josef Stalin,
“The death of one man is a tragedy.
The death of millions is a statistic.”
Okay, he didn’t actually say that, but it’s
an appropriate quote either way.
Today, we’re talking about a much smaller,
pettier kind of evil.
Sure, this anomaly can kill people - and has,
many, many times, in fact - but where it really
gets its kicks, is in making you feel like
crap on a more emotional level.
It’s SCP-056: Ironically known by the nickname,
“A Beautiful Person”, because on the inside,
this self-obsessed monster is anything but
beautiful.
This crafty creature spent what potentially
could have been hundreds of years around humans
before the SCP Foundation eventually located
and apprehended it, meaning you may have even
run into it at some point or another before
it was rightfully imprisoned.
How do you know if you had a brush with SCP-056?
Well, it’s difficult to know for sure, but
perhaps the biggest indicator is that it probably
annoyed the living hell out of you.
You see, SCP-056 is a sentient shapeshifter
with a subtle mind-warping ability, whose
entire reason for existence is using those
abilities to make everyone around them feel
incredibly inadequate.
They don’t have any kind of consistent or
“true” form, only a consistent ethos - And
that ethos is “Anything you can do, I can
do better.”
And we mean this in its most literal sense.
Whenever SCP-056 is left with a person, an
animal, or even an object, the second all
eyes are taken off of it, it’ll become a
slightly better version of whatever it’s
encountering.
If the thing in question is capable of thinking
or feeling, it will not feel good about this
development.
Just like we said, it’s probably not going
to bring the world to its knees, but it sure
would suck to know SCP-056.
Its lack of a consistent form makes SCP-056
a little difficult to think about visually
- Which was also the reason it was so hard
to catch - but for the sake of consistency,
we’ll present it here with one of its favorite
forms: A woman who’s a real dead ringer
for “perfection” - famous actress Scarlett
Johanssen, of Black Widow fame.
So what is it really like to experience SCP-056’s
anomalous effects first-hand?
Well, we’ll take you through a little crash-course
in anomalous insecurity and frustration.
Let’s say that this creature, in human form,
is one of your co-workers.
When the Foundation discovered it, it was
working in the fashion industry, but who knows
what job it could have held before then?
If it worked in your office, it was probably
that one irritating coworker who always wore
nicer clothes than you, had a brighter, whiter
smile, and much better hair.
While you were thanklessly toiling away on
the reports for the latest financial quarter,
056 was schmoozing with your boss on golf
lunches, scoring perfect games and promotions
one “hole in one” at a time.
Of course, they tell you about it at the water
cooler.
Like everyone who’s feeling inadequate,
maybe you buy yourself a new car.
A vintage Cadillac convertible that makes
you look more like a gangster than an office
drone.
Awesome!
That’ll make all those feelings that you’re
not good enough go away.
You even buy yourself a stylish pair of sunglasses,
and start cruising around town with the top
down, hoping that everyone sees how cool you
are now.
But when you’re stopped at a stop light,
you see something approaching in the lane
next to you.
It’s the latest Rolls Royce, in jet black.
And who would be behind the wheel but SCP-056,
in Armani shades that are much nicer than
yours.
It grins and nods to you in the mirrors, and
you can feel your soul shriveling up inside
you, only to be replaced by rage and resentment.
Maybe later that month, you and all your co-workers
are at a bar, enjoying drinks.
Of course, SCP-056 is the best dressed one
there, and is telling all the most interesting
stories.
Your jokes don’t get any laughs, but 056
is bringing down the house with every word.
Feeling ignored, you decide to get everyone
a round on you.
056 is a designated driver in its new Rolls
Royce, so you just decide to get them a Pepsi
instead.
However, by the time you return to their stool,
they’re nowhere to be seen.
A tall glass of Coca Cola with ice cubes is
sitting on the bar next to their seat.
Perhaps one day you finally snap and decide
you can’t take it anymore.
You’ll meet SCP-056 after work and put this
showboating jerk in its place at long last.
You sneak up on it in an alley with a knife
in your palm and swing for it, but your blade
never makes contact.
SCP-056 unleashes some high-level Jiu-Jitsu
move on you, easily knocks the knife from
your hands, and beats the living hell out
of you.
When you’re later convicted of attempted
murder, all you can do is scream “They made
me do it!”
Again and again in your prison cell.
Envy can do crazy things to a person.
But there’s more!
Really, if you lose your mind from an encounter
with SCP-056, you still haven’t done too
badly.
While its methods of attack are more commonly
psychological, as we alluded to earlier, SCP-056
is definitely not above committing some pretty
horrifying acts of violence.
SCP-056 was discovered in its clothing design
job after causing an unusually high number
of murders, suicides, and mental breakdowns
among its coworkers.
However, things took an even more unpleasant
turn when the Foundation sent personnel to
detain it.
SCP-056 reacted poorly to this show of potential
force, and turned into something even more
dangerous than the Foundation planned for
in getting it under control.
We don’t know exactly what it transformed
into due to SCP Foundation redactions, but
our guesses for what it transformed into would
either be a giant monster, a Rambo-esque unstoppable
super-soldier, or something like one of those
huge killer robots from Robocop.
Pick your favorite down there in the comments,
but whatever the case, it caused the unfortunate
deaths of seventeen agents and ten civilians.
The incident was blamed on an employee at
the company going postal and deciding to kill
a bunch of innocents, which...Technically
wasn’t untrue?
Not long after, Foundation operatives were
able to tranquilize SCP-056.
Perhaps you think this nasty little monster
decided to mellow out a little bit after being
contained, but if you did think that, I’m
afraid you’d be dead wrong.
It just decided to start terrorizing Foundation
staff with its infuriating anomalous abilities
instead.
Wait until you see this!
Compared to a lot of entities locked up at
the SCP Foundation, SCP-056 really lives in
the lap of luxury.
It has a well-furnished room, easy access
to members of staff, and is given permission
to interact with any object it desires - As
long as those objects aren’t anomalous.
Why is this Euclid-Class anomaly with over
seventeen dead Foundation staff members to
its name given so much leeway?
Well, to answer that, remember the ethos:
“Anything you can do, I can do better.”
And this holds true, whether we’re talking
physical appearance or one’s capacity to
commit tremendous acts of violence.
The Foundation is forced to cater to most
of SCP-056’s whims, or it’ll become a
hell of a lot more dangerous in response to
any kind of external resistance.
See?
We told you it’d suck to have to know this
thing, and nobody knows that better than the
employees of the SCP Foundation who are forced
to interact with it on a daily basis for containment
and testing.
First, let’s take a look at some of the
forms it’s occupied since it began its time
at the SCP Foundation.
When a researcher brought in their beloved
pooch, SCP-056 decided to flex on it by becoming
a beautiful, well-groomed labrador retriever.
When younger female staff passed it, it decided
to once again take on its Scarlett Johanssen
form.
When speaking to a group of other researchers
about intelligence, it became a female researcher
with an IQ score thirty points higher than
the top-scoring human researcher on site.
When it took a trip to the containment site’s
gym, where the guards and mobile task forces
exercise and train, it decided to take its
flexes to a more literal level.
It transformed into a ripped, hunky bodybuilder,
who strutted into the middle of the gym and
bench-pressed 250 kilos, no problem.
This was thirty kilos more than the strongest
human guard working at the site.
Its commitment to being the best is so great
that when left alone in its containment chamber,
it will sometimes literally transform into
a nicer couch than the one the Foundation
provided for it.
Doesn’t it just make your blood boil?
But wait, there’s more!
Just in case this wasn’t absurd enough,
the Foundation felt like testing the limits
of its anomalous abilities.
In particular, they were extremely eager to
see if 056 had a secret default form.
They left it alone with a single security
camera in order to observe what it transformed
into when not being observed.
And can you guess what happened?
It turned into an even higher-quality security
camera, and stared back.
While the transformations can only take place
while 056 isn’t being observed, it’s very
astute at creating periods where it can’t
be seen or interacted with.
Vision or camera feeds have been known to
briefly go foggy in order to facilitate a
transformation.
It’s fitting that 056, being the ultimate
diva, will only ever let people look at it
on its own terms.
It also seems to get off on causing shame
- and the degree to which that statement is
metaphorical is, well, open to interpretation.
Staff members made insecure by its antics
feel compelled to enter its cell and verbally
berate it, at which point 056 will shame them
even harder, and send them out with their
tail between their legs.
It’s like every toxic friend rolled into
one nasty package.
Curious as to what else SCP-056 was capable
of, the Foundation conducted a few other tests
between SCP-056 and their personnel.
Here, they discovered that 056 seemed incredibly
responsive to intent.
When a D-Class was sent in with a knife and
the intent to kill, 056 transformed into a
lean, athletic man, before disarming and killing
the D-Class.
A somewhat attractive D-Class female was sent
in with a bottle of wine.
056 became a beautiful woman and accepted
the wine, before taking a sip, and spitting
it back into the D-Class’ face.
A mixed-gender pair of D-Classes were sent
in next with no real intent.
056 became an attractive woman in a well-tailored
business suit, who looked over the pair before
kicking them both out.
Ten male D-Classes were sent in after that.
056 turned into a beautiful woman in a low-cut
dress, and simply waited until the ten men
were driven mad with desire and began physically
fighting one another for her affection.
She watched them doing this for seven minutes
before laughing and leaving the simp squadron
to duke it out alone.
In another test, a female staff member with
Level 4 clearance, who was also judged to
be the most attractive woman on site - which
seems like an HR issue that the Ethics Committee
should probably look into - was sent into
056’s testing chamber.
056 became, quote, “An extremely aesthetically
pleasing woman, who displayed a large lexicon
and understanding of management skills.”
Unquote.
The two spoke for around 90 minutes until
the Level 4 staff member stormed out in a
rage.
Recently, 056 has requested access to the
internet, saying that the Foundation has been
unable to provide it with enough sycophants,
and that via the internet, the whole world
will be able to see its face.
If ever 056 got onto YouTube and transformed
into a more successful SCP Channel, I just
don’t think we’d be able to take it!
Thankfully, this request was denied.
Legends about the end of the world often come
with the sounds of thundering hooves, and
the approach of Four Horsemen.
War.
Famine.
Pestilence.
Death.
They will descend on the world and usher in
the end of days.
It’s a terrifying idea, these horsemen bringing
darkness and decay wherever they go, as the
world collapses all around them.
We all hope that we’ll never see the day
that the Four Horsemen come.
Unfortunately, some unlucky people out there
have already encountered their own version
of the Horsemen of the Apocalypse, shadowy
riders with inhuman strength that follow disaster,
destruction, and untold suffering.
The SCP Foundation came across a series of
journal entries written by Dave Harkand, an
infantryman in the British Expeditionary Force
during World War I. That first World War was
a nightmare for all who fought in it, a sea
of bloodshed and gunfire, young men crouched
terrified in foxholes and wondering when death
would finally come for them.
The horrors of war are notable, but not exactly
the sort of thing the SCP Foundation preoccupies
itself with.
So what was so captivating, so specifically
terrible, about Dave Harkand’s journals?
They described his experiences over the course
of The Battle of the Somme, and an anomaly
he encountered there that was unlike anything
he had ever seen.
No military training, no combat experience,
could have prepared him for what was waiting,
hiding in the fog of war.
His first journal entry began on a lighthearted
note, or as lighthearted as one can be in
the face of combat.
“June 27th, 1916
Finally arrived at the front!
I picked up this little journal while I was
in Paris, figured I might as well keep record
of my heroics on the battlefield.
Quite chuffed to finally be in action, though
it seems I'm the only one.
Most of these blokes have been fighting for
a couple months now, and they look downright
dreadful.
Mud all over the uniform, and their faces
are so pale, look like they haven't eaten
or slept for months.”
A few days later, he began to hear stirrings
amongst his fellow soldiers, and strange sounds
that rocked their barracks.
He described the first unsettling incident:
“July 2nd, 1916
Woke in the early hours of the morning.
Ground was shaking, damn near shook me out
into the muck on the dugout floor.
Poor blokes in the bunks on the other side
looked liked they had seen a ghoul.
Pair of Northern Irish lads from Kitchener’s
Armies if I remember right.
Kept muttering about a Nuckatee?...Were both
gripping a gold crucifix.
Was about to lay my head back down and get
a wink of shuteye when I ended up scrambling
into the mud.
Loudest damn thing I'd ever heard.
Thought it was the Hun Artillery bout to mark
us with a whizz-bang, only problem was, never
did get the bang.
This morning asked our brass hat about the
Artillery barrage.
Gave me a funny look, and asked what the bloody
hell I was talking about.”
The next day, Dave went searching for the
source of the loud sound.
He didn’t find any evidence of artillery,
but instead found something he had never seen
before.
It was a crater, shaped like a giant horse’s
hoof.
He brushed it off as just another oddity of
the battlefield, a bit strange but nothing
to be concerned about.
There were more important things at hand,
anyway.
The next day, he finally saw combat first-hand,
and things only got more bizarre and frightening.
“July 3rd, 1916
Huns made a push today, first time they've
moved in our region.
First time I'd ever seen combat.
It's not romantic and adventurous.
It's terrifying, and deadly.
My hands can't stop shaking, already messed
up the chit once.
The Huns had our outfit up against a wall,
damn near overran us, didn't help that it
rained the night before making our fox hole
filled to the brim with muck.
One of the Fritz came right at me…just…I
put one right between his eyes.
Fell right at the edge of the trench, and
had to look him in the eyes, poor lad couldn't
have been more than 17 or 18.
Martin, one of those Irish lads, is gone.
Was unlike anything I'd ever seen, one moment
he's standing shooting at the Huns, all of
the sudden, the mud starts boiling.
Fore anyone can react, Mud just flies everywhere,
everyone else is suddenly knocked down off
their feet.
I look up, and he’s just gone.
Wasn't even body parts left.
Haven't told anyone…but I'd swear that there
was bones coming up from underneath him right
before the mud went flying.
His mate, Brendan, was digging in the mud
for hours, looking for the crucifix.”
Martin’s body was never found, no matter
how they searched.
A little over a week later, things got even
worse.
“July 14th & 15th, 1916
Huns tried to push this morning in the rain.
I was in the machine gun nest with Brendan,
the other Irish chap in my unit.
They kept coming and coming, and getting stuck
in the mud, and I just kept shooting.
Sun is rising.
I'm on watch till 8, at least that's what
the Brasshat said.
I've started losing track of how much times
been passing.
There's something out there.
Something lurking out in the mud and dead
Huns.
Nearly dozed off last night, listening to
the moans of the blighty wounded stuck out
in No-man's land.
Poor souls got left behind.
Saw something out of the edge of my vision,
something big.
Couldn't quite make it out, it was much darker
than usual, overcast sky was obscuring the
full moon.
Heard a couple of screams, but whatever it
was, was gone before my flare hit the sky.”
This would not be Dave’s last sighting of
the large, dark figure.
This mysterious shadow would appear again,
several days later.
And there would be more of them.
“July 30th, 1916
I've been seeing them at the edge of my vision,
ever since that first night.
They're huge, but they move so damn fast that
they're gone before I can get a clear look.
Or at least, that's how it was mucking out
until today.
Thick fog and mist rolled in this morning,
blanketed everything.
We figured the Huns might use it to launch
another push.
Bastards have been pushing non-stop since
the 20th.
Saw it, through the fog, looked like a shadow,
hiding in the mist.
Some sort of Horse like creature, with a something
dragging along the ground, and a giant lump
where the rider would sit…cept the lump
started moving.
Could have sworn it was a person, or something
that looked like a person.
Sat up, and the things dragging along the
ground reached out in front of it and picked
up something, thought it was a couple dead
Jerry's…until they started squirming.
I'll never forget the noise it made.
Louder than a banshee, shrill and twisted.
It looked right at me.
Two pairs of red glowing orbs.”
Two weeks after meeting eyes with this chilling
apparition, Dave wrote a short note in his
journal:
“August 5th
Brendan calls them Nuckelavees.
Won't tell me much more than that.
Beginning to understand why all these blokes
looked so terrified when I first arrived.”
It wasn’t until another week had passed
that Dave would truly begin to understand
just what kind of monster he was up against.
Not the enemy soldiers, but something far
more horrible.
Something inhuman.
“August 13th
Bloody hell.
They're nightmares.
Been on watch two nights in a row, one just…appeared
right there, right in front of me.
20 feet, had to be at least 20 feet away.
Towered into the sky.
Got my flare to go off in time to see it pick
up a couple wounded Jerry's in the mud.
They don't have bloody skin.
There's just muscle, and fat.
The thing on its back…wasn't human, no way
could it be human.
Had no skin either, no legs, just merged straight
into the horse at the stomach.
I took a couple shots at it with my rifle…did
absolutely nothing, like I was shooting it
with a sling shot.
It stopped soon as my flare reached its highest
point, and turned.
Looked straight down at me, both the horse
and the…thing on its back.
It smiled.”
He tried to talk to his superiors, tried to
warn of the horrors he was seeing and the
danger he felt they posed, but they wouldn’t
listen.
Night after night, the creatures came back.
“August 17th 1916
Been assigned night watch the past four nights
straight.
Tried to tell the brass hat about the nuckelavees.
Didn't believe me.
Said it was the shell shock playing with my
head.
Had to put a sock in it, and keep on.
It keeps coming back.
Every night.
Same spot, 20 feet in front of me.
Picks up wounded Jerry's, turns and looks…and
then it's gone.
It's playing with me, I'm sure of it.
Last night there was another one too.
Four of those things on its back, did the
same damn thing.”
A few days later, Dave spotted something that
made his blood run cold.
“7:00 A.M.
August 20th 1916
Jerry's made a big push yesterday.
Rained two days ago, all day, so the muck
was deep.
We were on the machinegun again in the pillbox.
So many of them in no-man's land last night,
couldn't tell the dead from the living.
Haven't slept in six days.
There were five tonight.
Three of them had more than one of those…things
on their back.
The one that keeps coming back…dropped something.
Saw it shine in the flare light.
10:00 A.M.
August 20th 1916
Went out into the mud where it appears every
night.
Found Martin's crucifix and tin hat.”
Whatever this thing was, it had taken Martin.
It seemed to want Dave to know that, too.
It left behind Martin’s lost things for
him to find.
As if it was gloating.
As if it already knew that it had won.
“August 20th 1916
They're getting bold, saw one out in broad
daylight.
Pretty sure it was the same one.
Buried itself in the mud, just lying there…waiting.
We're going over the top at three.
There are more out there now…all doing the
same thing…god help us.”
Dave Harkand was declared Missing in Action
on August 20, 1916, following an attempted
counterattack against the German forces.
Another soldier from his unit, Brendan O’Malley,
was also reported Missing in Action on the
same day.
Though Dave’s body was never recovered,
his journal was found 20 feet away from the
edge of the German trenches two months later.
Poor Dave Harkand had no idea what he, and
the rest of his fellow soldiers, encountered
out there.
He didn’t live to learn more, but he came
face to face with SCP-3456.
SCP-3456 is not one being, but rather a group
of quadrupeds that vaguely resemble horses.
From a distance, their silhouette looks like
that of a horse with a human riding on its
back.
However, once the observer gets closer, they
will notice some disturbing differences.
These creatures do not look like any ordinary
horse.
They are smooth and hairless, with translucent
skin and three-toed hooves.
Anyone unfortunate enough to get close to
one of these creatures will be able to see
through their skin to the blood vessels and
muscle underneath.
They will also notice that there is no rider
perched atop the creature’s back at all.
The humanoid shape is a part of the creature’s
body, an extension of them, fused to its back.
The humanoid figure consists of a pair of
long arms, which drag along the ground as
the creature moves, and a head.
The arms end in sharpened bones rather than
fingers, and the head has mostly human features,
with the exception of a hole where the nose
should be.
The creatures vary greatly in size, with the
largest on record measuring at a height of
30 meters and a width of 15.
They appear to be invulnerable, at least when
it comes to any traditional human weaponry
they have currently been exposed to.
Gunfire, explosives, swords and arrows, and
even nuclear blasts seem to have no effect.
If you happen to get a look at one of these
bulletproof abominations in person, then I
am so sorry.
You are as good as gone.
Because once you’ve seen one of these creatures,
they have also seen you, and they will not
stop until they have taken you.
They will track you, stalk you, hide buried
in mud and nestled in bushes.
They will wait for the opportune moment, and
they will reach out with their unnaturally
long arms, smiling with no lips as their blood
red eyes burn like hellfire, and you will
disappear forever.
They will travel far beyond the site where
they first appeared, until they have finally
captured their prey.
This isn’t an SCP-096 situation, either.
They aren’t punishing you for seeing their
face.
They want to be seen, and will go out of their
way to show themselves to people until they
have captured as many as they want.
No one knows what becomes of SCP-3456’s
victims, but they are never seen again.
Though items once belonging to the missing
people may resurface, their bodies are never
found.
There is only one way to escape from SCP-3456,
and that is to find and cross a body of fresh
water.
For reasons unknown, the entities are unable
or unwilling to cross rivers, streams, and
lakes.
The Foundation first discovered this during
an operation in Iraq, in which several agents
encountered a group of SCP-3456 manifestations.
They fled from the monsters, and quickly retreated
across the Tigris river.
Once they had reached the other side, they
saw that the creatures had not followed them
onto the bridge.
Instead, they remained at the riverbank on
the other side, watching, and waiting.
This was quickly noted, and added to potential
containment procedures, though the exact reason
for SCP-3456’s dislike of fresh water is
currently unknown.
In Dave Harkland’s journals, his fellow
soldier described the creatures as “Nuckelavees,”
but would not elaborate beyond that.
So what is a Nuckelavee?
The word refers to a creature from the waters
of Orkney, a group of islands on the northern
coast of Scotland.
Their name is thought to come from an Orcadian
word meaning “Devil of the Sea,” and they
truly are like something out of hell.
These creatures are native to the ocean, and
supposedly take on another form when in their
natural habitat, but no one knows what they
truly look like.
On land, the creature is a hybrid of man and
horse, with a large snout like that of a pig,
and a single red eye that burns like the embers
of a fire.
It has no hair or skin, just raw, tissue and
bone dripping black blood.
Everything about the creature is malicious
and deadly, intended to bring harm and calamity
to humans.
Even its breath is toxic, thought to cause
disease, plague, and the death of crops.
As they are native to the ocean, they detest
fresh water, and will not cross it even in
pursuit of their prey.
They will also not appear when it is raining.
In the legends of the Nuckelavee, they do
have a natural enemy.
A creature from Orcadian folklore known as
the Mither of the Sea is said to have the
power to keep the monsters from coming ashore
during the Summer months.
The Mither, or Mother, is a benevolent force
of nature, giving warmth to the oceans and
life to the beings of the water and the land.
Though SCP-3456 has appeared during the Summer
months, it has never been spotted in the Orkney
region during this time of year.
Perhaps this is a coincidence, but some Foundation
researchers have proposed a research expedition
to the area in order to look for the kindly
ocean spirit.
So far, this proposal has been denied.
SCP-3456 is classified as Keter, and there
is currently no way to effectively contain
it.
All previous attempts to contain or to neutralize
the horsemen have failed, though the Foundation
is always looking for new methods to attempt.
Currently, any personnel who see the horsemen
will be given Class G amnestics at a treatment
center located within one kilometer of a freshwater
stream, river, or lake.
All references to the horsemen have been scrubbed
from historical records, and any sightings
are to be blamed on PTSD, shock, and trauma-induced
hysteria.
Areas that are likely to attract SCP-3456,
such as war zones and areas impacted by natural
disasters, are to be heavily monitored by
the Foundation.
In the event of a disaster, Foundation personnel
will be sent to help with evacuation in order
to get all civilians away from SCP-3456 as
quickly as possible.
So what is SCP-3456?
Is it the dreaded Nuckelavee from folktales
and whispered fireside warnings?
There are some notable differences between
the stories and what the Foundation encountered.
SCP-3456 does not seem to have come from the
ocean, nor is it limited to only appearing
around Orkney.
These beasts seem to manifest from thin air,
and disappear the same way when their nasty
work is done.
But, folklore and passing down stories often
distorts things.
Details change, and others are added or left
out.
In the original stories, the Nuckelavee was
thought to be the cause of famines, plagues,
and disasters.
Perhaps it was simply drawn to these events,
lured there by the scent of pure human misery.
Perhaps the Nuckelavee is not just similar
to SCP-3456, but the two are one and the same.
Or perhaps they are something entirely different.
Whatever the case may be, there is nothing
we can do to stop them.
War, famine, pestilence, and death are everywhere,
they are inevitable and unfortunate parts
of life on earth.
So, it seems, are these deadly riders, these
monsters that are neither horse nor man, but
still somehow both.
Every time we wage war, every time disaster
strikes, they will come to watch, to pick
through the rubble, and to smile.
Maybe, we don’t need to dread the coming
of the Horsemen of the Apocalypse.
They are already here.
There are many things in this world that we
do not, and perhaps cannot, understand.
The SCP Foundation dedicates itself to researching
and containing these things, but even they
occasionally encounter something that defies
any kind of true understanding.
The unknown is terrifying to the average person,
but for an organization that specializes in
knowing the unknowable, a mystery that refuses
to be understood can be downright nightmarish.
A Foundation expedition team lost contact
with their command while on a mission in the
Northern Ural mountains of Russia.
After six hours of silence, radio contact
was reestablished, though video feed continued
to be disabled.
A lone agent, Dr. Felsenstein, called out
desperately over the radio waves, begging
for someone, anyone, to answer him.
Command responded, requesting a status update
on the rest of his crew.
At first, they were met only with the wet,
hollow sound of Felsenstein weeping.
Finally, he explained that they were all dead,
and he was the only man left standing.
“Something got him,” he said, of fellow
agent Myers.
“It was long…slippery.
I saw a grown man pulled into a tiny hole.”
He began to hyperventilate, his descriptions
becoming less and less coherent.
Command offered to send reinforcements to
collect the survivor, but he begged them not
to.
He was beyond saving at this point, describing
himself as “nothing but a walking corpse.”
After slipping into a crevice, Felsenstein
had broken his ankle and torn a hole in his
hazmat suit.
Command honored his insistence that no reinforcements
be sent in, but encouraged him to try and
pull himself back to the surface and retrieve
additional data.
Even if he was doomed, he could still provide
valuable information on the threat he encountered.
When Felsenstein attempted to free himself
from the crevice, he slipped deeper into the
crack in the ground.
Pushing through his fear of being crushed
to death, he tried again.
Fighting against the burning of the toxic
air in his lungs and the straining of his
muscles, he finally pulled himself to freedom.
Then, he took in his surroundings.
He was at the edge of a chasm, so deep he
could not see the bottom.
He posited that he was somewhere underneath
or inside of a mountain.
There was a putrid smell in the air, burning
his eyes, his skin, everything.
Command told him to remain calm, still hoping
for the possibility of a rescue.
Meanwhile, on their end, hostile forces were
closing in and forcing them to evacuate.
They asked Felsenstein to continue describing
his surroundings, so that his account might
be recorded for the archives.
They would attempt to come back with reinforcements
when it was safe for them to do so.
As Felsenstein made it deeper into the chasm,
he was engulfed in a thick yellow fog.
Through the haze, he could make out thousands
of eggs, and piles of meat being devoured
by small creatures with the bodies of grubs
and the faces of human infants.
The creatures did not respond to his presence,
either unaware of him or too consumed with
their feeding to care.
As he passed the creatures, he spotted a massive
black temple with architecture like nothing
he had seen before, all polished and sharp
with angles that hurt his eyes to look at.
As he stopped to take a better look, he realized
he was still moving somehow, without moving
his feet.
He was being dragged by something, tendrils
wrapped around his legs and pulling him along
against his will, leaving a trail of his blood
behind.
As he was dragged, dozens of what seemed like
humans watched him.
The final words recorded on the audio transcript
were the most troubling of all.
Felsenstein saw what he described as an “angel”
with a thousand wings.
The angel pulled him into her embrace, clutching
him to her breast…and the connection was
lost.
Dr. Felsenstein was never seen again.
His colleagues’ bodies were never recovered.
The entire team of men was lost forever, inside
the incomprehensible hellhole known as SCP-2133.
SCP-2133 is an unnamed village in the Northern
Ural mountains in Eastern Europe, with an
estimated population of around fifty people.
The village is considered dangerous to enter
without proper hazmat gear, due to the presence
of a wide variety of microbial pathogens within
its limits, including those which cause leprosy,
pneumonic, septicemic, and bubonic plagues,
typhoid fever, influenza, cholera, and smallpox.
A veritable hypochondriac’s worst nightmare.
In spite of this cocktail of diseases in which
they live, the residents of 2133 seem to be
resistant to the negative effects of infection.
Of course, they experience physical symptoms,
to the point of visible disfigurement or disability,
but they do not die at a rate consistent with
the sheer volume of deadly pathogens present
in their town.
The people of SCP-2133 do not leave it.
The Foundation cannot fully determine whether
they cannot leave, or simply choose not to,
but whatever the case may be they stay within
the limits of their village.
Their relative resistance to disease, small
population, and refusal to leave the boundaries
of their village are all unusual, but that
is far from the most unusual thing about the
population of SCP-2133.
The people of the village age and die, yes,
but they do not stay dead.
They engage in what can only be described
as some kind of reincarnation.
When a resident of the village dies, they
are placed in the field, where they quickly
decay.
On the night of the first new moon, a newborn
infant is pulled from the soil where the decaying
body once lay.
The reborn version of each person looks like
their previous self, and carries all of the
memories they had in their previous life.
The Foundation performed extensive soil tests
on the field where this curious rebirth takes
place, and found that the soil there contains
high levels of embryonic fluid.
Beyond the presence of this fluid in the earth,
it is unknown how exactly this reincarnation
process works.
The residents of the village, known as SCP-2133-1,
speak an old Russian dialect and occasionally
agree to be interviewed by Foundation staff
fluent in this dialect.
Though they will sit for interviews and chat
with Foundation personnel, they are secretive
about their lives, their history, and the
culture of their little village.
The first resident to be successfully interviewed
was an elderly man named Aristarkh, who was
missing his left arm and had necrosis on most
of his visible skin.
The interview was conducted by Dr. Judith
Low, one of the head researchers on the case.
She asked the man how far back he was able
to remember, and he recounted a time of “Tsars
and Khans.”
When Dr. Low pressed the man about the rebirth
that his people practice, he responded that
it was “The Church of the Red Harvest.
We serve until the end.
That is the terms of our agreement.”
Dr. Low asked him why he, and the rest of
his people, would continue to live their lives
this way when it causes them such obvious
suffering.
He explained, simply: “There is no choice.
The land calls.
We answer.”
She continued to push the issue, inquiring
about how this all began so many years ago.
He explained that a priestess came to the
village many lifetimes ago.
She offered the people paradise, in exchange
for their servitude.
However, as the years passed, the people became
more and more exhausted.
They feared that they had failed somehow,
and were being punished.
Aristarkh became visibly upset at this point
in the interview, but continued to insist:
“The Church of the Red Harvest is truth.
There is no other.”
The second interview was conducted again by
Dr. Judith Low, who spoke with Anya, a young
girl who appeared to be between the ages of
six and eight.
Low greeted the girl, and attempted to ask
her first question, but Anya simply said:
“You don’t belong here.
Leave.”
Low brushed this off, and offered the girl
medical assistance, but was rebuffed again:
“You are not of the covenant.
You will never understand.”
Dr. Low asked Anya to elaborate on the nature
of this covenant, and her explanation was
similar to that of the previous interviewee.
There was an agreement made, a long time ago,
and now the people of the village would serve
until the end of time.
Again, she insisted that the Foundation should
leave, and did not belong in the town.
Finally, irritated with the questions, Anya
had only this to say about the church: “The
church was here long before the village.
A church of stone beneath the earth.
It is sacred.
A church of wood was built atop it, for the
heresy of the cross - before we embraced the
true faith.
The Karcist Alka will enlighten you.
You are only alive because she has chosen
to let you live.”
Hearing the word Karcist probably gives you
some indication as to what’s really going
on here - If the disease, corruption, and
mutation of the flesh didn’t give you enough
of a clue.
This horror is Sarkic through and through.
Dr. Low’s final question was a seemingly
easy one: does the village have a name?
As soon as the words left Dr. Low’s lips,
Anya began to vomit up a thick black substance,
ending the interview.
Instances of SCP-2133-1 are largely apathetic
toward Foundation agents, unless they get
in the way of their routine.
The agents are allowed to go inside of any
buildings in the village, with one notable
exception: the Church of the Red Harvest.
Any attempts to learn more about the church
or enter its walls are met with refusal to
explain, or, in some cases, outright hostility.
Though the villagers are largely peaceful
toward the Foundation, they are not the only
entity living in SCP-2133.
Throughout the village, there are instances
of something known as SCP-2133-2.
These organic structures, which have the appearance
of dark red tentacles, display overt hostility
toward outsiders and will attack any that
get too close.
They are especially aggressive to any outsiders
that attempt to enter the church.
Tissue samples were taken from the tentacles
for observation, and they were found, horrifyingly
enough, to genetically resemble tissue samples
from humans.
After the interview with Anya, the Foundation
research team determined that entering the
church was of the utmost importance.
Mobile Task Force Beta-7 was dispatched for
this mission, and, after the residents of
the town were restrained, a team of twelve
operatives was sent in.
They were armed with radios, video recorders,
hazmat suits, and air tanks.
As they attempted to enter the church, the
tentacles attacked, but were subdued with
flamethrowers.
Apparently, like most living things, they
are not immune to fire.
Inside the church, the research team found
small idols crafted from bone and leather,
and a few others made from tumors, hanging
from iron hooks on the ceiling.
At the building’s center was an entrance
to a system of caves and caverns beneath the
village, stretching beyond its borders into
the mountains.
Several previously unseen organisms, designated
only as SCP-2133-3, were discovered inside.
One was terminated, and taken back to the
Foundation for an autopsy.
The creature was humanoid in nature, with
swollen organs and flesh, and an overgrowth
of bone and fatty tissue.
After the autopsy, the team of operatives
refreshed their air tanks and headed back
into the village to continue their research.
About fifty minutes into their expedition,
all contact was lost out of nowhere.
Six hours later, Dr. Felsenstein would make
his infamous radio contact, and the nightmare
would unfold from there.
Currently, SCP-2133 is easily contained.
A security perimeter is maintained at a ten-kilometer
radius around the town, preventing any civilians
from making their way inside.
There are guards positioned along the perimeter,
under the guise of a Russian military base.
In spite of the horrifying nature of SCP-2133,
the villagers do not seem to pose an immediate
threat to anyone.
They simply want to be left alone, to till
the fields and attend their church, in an
endless cycle of winters and summers as they
wait for the end to come.
As they hope that finally, their agreement
will be honored, and they will find peace.
The ocean is a terrifying place.
We’ve all heard the statistics.
More than 80 percent of the ocean remains
unexplored.
That’s most of the water covering the globe,
completely unmapped and unobserved by science.
It’s a scary thought to dwell on, realizing
there’s more water than land on earth, and
the sheer expanse of that water is so large
that we’ve been unable to fully explore
all of it.
Just think, there are places in the ocean
that have never been seen by a human.
Who knows what’s down there?
If there were ever a personification of the
fear of the unknown, the ocean could definitely
be it.
Ancient shipwrecks sunk to the ocean floor,
unknown sea creatures hiding away from humanity,
and the general isolation of the suffocating
dark blue the ocean swallows its victims with,
all of these are images that come to mind
when thinking about the vast and mysterious
depths of the sea.
And no one is more familiar with nautical
mysteries than the SCP Foundation.
Today we’ll be taking a look at SCP-5007,
the Bass Strait, a wave of oceanic anomalies
fit to make any seasoned sailor shiver in
fear.
is an area of ocean dividing Tasmania and
the Australian mainland.
It’s also the location of an unusually high
amount of disappearances.
Sailors disappearing from their ships, fishermen
leaving in the night and never coming back,
even civilians disappearing from the shores
that connect to the Strait.
The Foundation was aware of these disappearances
since 1858, but were only able to craft theories
about what was causing them.
Was it an anomalous group of interest?
Hostile aerial entities patrolling the skies
above the Strait?
Phenomena associated with unidentified flying
objects?
What about subterranean anomalies,weather
patterns, or time dilation?
For nearly a century, the Foundation was unable
to determine the cause of the high number
of disappearances in the Bass Strait, and
then, the phenomena suddenly revealed itself.
In 1980, on a beach connected to the strait,
Agent Taberner, an operative of the SCP Foundation,
was vacationing with his wife, Mary, and his
three young children.
The Taberner family was simply enjoying their
day, when they saw what looked like balloons
in the sky.
They were approaching quickly, and naturally,
the family moved closer.
What happened next was a whirlwind, and those
balloons the family was so interested in lifted
them up from the ground, and carried them
away.
Agent Taberner tried to fight back, but there
was nothing he could do, except report to
the Foundation what had occurred.
And the organization responded in full force.
The Foundation’s research discovered that
reports of UFOs and lights in the sky had
coincided with many disappearances in the
Strait, and that this was a pattern.
The search for the four lost Taberner family
members had become a large-scale investigation
into unexplained disappearances along the
Bass Strait, and within 3 weeks, it was determined
that these patterns were consistent across
the entirety of the Strait’s coastal regions.
Some witnesses were interviewed, but the vast
majority of these abduction cases had no witnesses
whatsoever.
Of the minimal reports filed, the Foundation
was told that there were lights in the sky,
and the appearance of unidentified flying
objects described as having the appearance
of balloons.
One such witness interviewed was a man by
the name of Alan Stewart, a witness who was
present during the disappearance of former
Australian Prime Minister Harold Holt, whose
disappearance the Foundation believed may
have had a connection to the Bass Strait anomalies.
During the interview, Stewart claimed that
Holt and his family, while voyaging on their
yacht, decided to leave the boat and go for
a swim.
Holt turned to Stewart and asked him if he
could see the balloons around the cliff.
Stewart had no idea what Holt was talking
about, but Holt was insistent on seeing them.
He swam deeper out into the ocean, saying
that they weren’t normal balloons, and that
there was someone inside of them.
Stewart and Holt’s family called out for
him to come to shore, but he wouldn’t listen.
Stewart tried to rationalize what he saw next.
Maybe it was the current sweeping Holt away.
But he couldn’t lie to the Foundation interviewer.
Stewart saw Holt go further and further out
into the water, and suddenly, the Prime Minister
turned around.
He began swimming in the opposite direction.
And he was screaming.
Suddenly, Holt was lifted from the sea and
pulled into the air by something emerging
from the clouds.
The Foundation thanked Stewart for the interview,
and continued their investigation.
Two years later, in 1982, emergency services
received a large number of calls pertaining
to UFO sightings off the coast of Norman Bay,
Victoria.
The Foundation was quick to respond, alerting
task forces and local sites to prepare for
an investigation.
Upon arriving at the scene, they confirmed
the existence of multiple entities that would
later be documented as SCP-5007.
They evacuated civilians from the area and
successfully managed to capture the creature,
which was later transported to Site-40 for
containment.
It was a sight to behold.
The entity, now designated SCP-5007-S1, was
a cluster of human bodies fused between a
grouping of black tentacles of varying length.
Each tentacle was fused to the skin it touched
directly.
The stomachs of the corpses were grossly swollen
and distorted to massive sizes to hold large
quantities of gasses inside, the buoyancy
of which the entity used to achieve a passive
flight.
Across the entity’s surface were clusters
of eyes and bioluminescent, glowing organs.
Many of the humanoid components of the corpses
appeared to have been removed and misplaced
across various parts of the entity’s body.
What’s more, is that the Foundation discovered
that the human portions of SCP-5007 appeared
somewhat cognizant and aware of their situation.
Their vocalizations were incoherent and barely
understandable, consisting of gasping and
whimpering, but the corpses were observed
to implore other individuals to approach them
when encountered.
SCP-5007’s behavior during abduction scenarios
was documented during the initial containment
event, and due to the Foundation’s painstaking
research, a pattern was established between
all SCP-5007 encounters.
First, the victim would be alone, or otherwise
vulnerable in a coastal location.
SCP-5007 haven’t shown a preference for
weather, be they clear or hostile skies, but
they have localized all of their activity
to the Bass Strait, in small coastal towns,
beaches, or boats.
SCP-5007 will then move towards the shore,
stalking the victim before lowering its tentacles
and appendages to grab the individual, snatching
them into the sky.
An SCP-5007 instance can even abduct multiple
people at once.
One event observed had eight men from the
decks of a commercial fishing boat taken into
the sky in under 15 seconds.
Once captured, SCP-5007 instances will dart
across the water at a high speed, and take
their victims to an unknown location.
Discovering where SCP-5007 took their victims
became a top priority for the Foundation.
After extensive witness interviews and compiling
a database of likely victims, they determined
there must be at least 16 instances of SCP-5007
unaccounted for.
Personnel kept a close watch on the coastlines
and waters of the Bass Strait, and equipped
various marine task forces with research vessels
capable of tracking any instances if they
encountered them.
In 1985, the Foundation’s research efforts
paid off, and several survey teams operating
in the area reported a sighting of an extremely
large SCP-5007 instance heading towards a
coastal town.
A Mobile Task force was sent to track the
entity.
The team observed the entity from afar as
it stalked a private fishing boat.
Even from the distance, Foundation personnel
recognized the likenesses of several missing
persons as faces on the corpses of SCP-5007.
The Task force captain had to remind his team
to keep it together, claiming that they were
not people, but just parts of the specimen.
But everyone secretly knew the truth.
The fishing vessel was a private one, occupied
by a small family.
The entity slowly approached, and quickly
pulled a woman into the air.
The family panicked and quickly tried to reach
cover for safety, running into the ship’s
cabin.
The entity ran its tentacles along the boat
until it pulled the door open, snatching another
two victims.
The task force was unable to help them, as
their mission was to track the instance to
its origin point.
It was a horror to watch.
The task force implanted a tracking beacon
onto the entity, and quietly followed it out
to sea over the next four hours.
They then discovered a large, gray reef, with
several shipwrecks dotted across it.13 SCP-5007
instances floated over the area, some holding
onto the land-reef with their tentacles.
The entity dropped the abductees from the
fishing boat, who were coerced by the entities
into diving into a massive pool of water located
in the center of the reef.
One by one, each abductee was pulled below
the surface by something lurking inside the
pool.
All while the SCP-5007 instances watched.
Disgusted, the task force reported what they
observed to the main site, and the reef would
be designated as SCP-5007-A.
The Foundation’s analysis of the reef led
to the discovery that the rock covering it
seeped iron oxide from an unknown source,
and the rocks achieved growth at an anomalously
fast rate, often as little as 40 minutes.
All of the wrecked ships and aircraft that
washed across the shore of the reef were covered
with the dark stone.
The reef was teeming with anomalous marine
life, including SCP-5007, a red algae that
fed upon the freshly grown rock, marine worms
capable of levitation, spiders that lived
in silk retreats underneath the waterline,
small fish, and giant organisms resembling
large clumps of kelp, which the Foundation
had previously documented as SCP-4159 in a
separate investigation.
SCP-5007 often rested their tentacles on the
outcroppings of the reef while inactive.
But what caught the Foundation’s attention
the most was the giant pit located at the
reef’s center.
Unmanned exploration drones found that it
had a depth of at least 4000 meters and water
samples taken from the pit revealed large
quantities of human DNA, prehistoric bacteria,
and unknown compounds that possessed significant
life-preserving qualities.
When a being was submerged in the compound,
they were able to survive heavy injuries,
even when fully surrounded by the liquid and
unable to breathe.
The Foundation’s exploration of one of the
shipwrecks led them to a journal.
Most of it was illegible due to water damage,
but one passage survived, located in the back
of the book.
It detailed the experience of an unknown crew
member of a ship caught in a storm.
It reads:
“Moresby spied land ahead, and the boys
say there are giant balloons hanging over
the island.
We are all afeared, but there is naught we
can do but beach ourselves and hope for rescue.
Should I be killed in the crash, I want my
mates to give this journal to my Mary might
know I spent my last thinking only of her.”
The interior of the ship contained human remains
inside, but there were less skeletons than
the Foundation would expect for a ship of
its size.
The location of the rest of the bodies was
unknown.
Another event related to SCP-5007 the Foundation
documented involved
Frederick Valentich, a pilot engaged in a
training flight over the Bass Strait in 1978.
Valentich’s disappearance was marked by
his latest communication with air traffic
control, when he mistook an SCP-5007 instance
for an unidentified aircraft.
It seems like it's stationary.
What I'm doing right now is orbiting and the
thing is just orbiting on top of me.
Also it's got a green light and sort of metallic,
like it's all shiny on the outside.
Shortly after this, Valentich’s transmission
was interrupted by what was described as metallic,
scraping sounds, believed to be the SCP-5007
instance attacking the aircraft and jamming
its propellers with its mass.
After crashing into the reef, it was believed
that Valentich and his aircraft were pulled
beneath the surface of the pit, just as the
abductees had been prior.
The Foundation decided to construct a provisional
secure research facility on the reef.
They named it Site-40-R, and documented all
returns and departures of SCP-5007.
They also set up a series of containment procedures
that resulted in SCP-5007 returning with victims
83% less often then before the site’s construction.
But this was short lived.
In 2008, the site logged over thirty six instances
returning to the reef, with only two not having
any fresh abductees.
These instances' origins were unknown, and
it was as if they appeared out of thin air.
No other monitoring post had documented their
appearance, or even spotted them before they
arrived at the reef.
It was years later, in 2017, that the Foundation
eventually was able to successfully explore
what was deep inside the pit at the center
of the reef.
They already knew there was a large entity
lurking beneath, as evidenced by what happened
to the victims of SCP-5007 that were deposited
inside the pool.
All previous attempts to explore the pool
were met with failure, as the water pressure
of the pit’s depths caused all craft to
collapse due to hull damage.
This time, however, they managed to construct
a high-tech submarine, labeled the SCPS Nautilus,
which was capable of diving a maximum of 13,500
meters underwater.
They decided that a D-Class personnel would
be trained to man the submersible and carry
out the exploration.
The mission was simple.
The Nautilus was to dive to the bottom of
the pit and to describe the depth readings.
Cameras and a microphone were equipped to
the vessel.
Due to the depth, remote viewing of this footage
was impossible.
Instead, the Foundation had to physically
recollect the vessel in order to view the
footage.
Upon recovery, some of the footage suffered
data corruption, but what was there shook
those who viewed it to their core.
The footage showed the D-Class’s experience
going deeper inside the pit.
At first, it seemed ordinary.
The trench had a number of rocky outcroppings,
dotted with black-yellow vines growing along
the walls.
Also present were the various marine lifeforms,
such as the spiders or the fish.
Going deeper, the sub observed an SCP-5007
instance clinging to an outcropping.
Several tendrils emerging from the pits depths
were wrapped around the instance and holding
onto the entity, as if it were feeding from
it.
Another 16 SCP-5007 instances were seen resting
along the walls, each clinging to the outcropping.
As the sub went deeper, the D-Class remarked
that there were dozens of plane and shipwrecks,
but also well over a hundred SCP-5007 entities.
Most of them were held there by the black
tendrils.
The D-Class, as the sub went even deeper,
began noticing human remains.
No short amount of them, either.
Deep into the pit, there was a large mass
of human remains, covering the entirety of
the pit.
Bodies crushed and drained of blood, but still
possessing intact eyes.
Each individual was still alive, kept preserved
by the life-sustaining compounds found within
the water.
The bodies stared at the sub and moved, attempting
to grab onto the vehicle.
The D-Class swore they were trying to say
something, mouthing words to the camera of
the sub.
As the sub passed through the mass of bodies,
it emerged into a completely dark, black clearing
at the bottom of the pit.
For a second, the D-Class thought he was safe.
But then, a large black tentacle rapidly emerged
from below and grabbed onto the Nautilus,
dragging it even further into the depths.
The D-Class screamed and panicked, but there
was nothing he could do.
The tentacle possessed large clusters of eyes,
mouths, and human heads seemingly grafted
onto its mass.
And then there was another tentacle, and then
another.
The Nautilus was pulled to the bottom of the
pool.
The D-Class’s screams were still heard,
even as the picture cut out.
Sometimes, graphic, body-alerting images of
the tentacle's features were visible on the
screen, but most of the footage was indecipherable.
After minutes of distorted, corrupted footage,
the Nautilus was seen again, rapidly ascending
to the surface.
Somehow, it had managed to escape the entity
at the bottom of the pit.
Upon recovery of the craft, it was found that
the Nautilus was covered in a thick, organic
coating similar to a black slime mold, but
with dozens of eyes growing from it.
The D-Class inside showed severe psychological
damage and attempted to harm Foundation personnel.
They were terminated shortly after, due to
being a danger to those around them.
Following review of the footage, the Nautilus
was to be dismantled and incinerated, alongside
the remains of the D-Class.
A reinforced containment seal was fitted over
the pit, with the intention of keeping whatever
was down there isolated from the surface.
But this was short lived.
After the containment seal was fitted, Site-40
underwent a massive communications blackout.
Every device on the site received an email
containing a single image of a large eye,
taken from a security camera.
The text beneath it simply read “FOUND YOU”.
Some personnel who viewed the email underwent
anomalous changes, growing new physical features,
such as eyes and other various growths, across
their body.
The entirety of Site-40-R went offline, and
the Foundation could not establish contact.
In an emergency effort to do so, Mobile Task
Force Gamma-6, Deep Feeders, was sent to investigate.
The task force’s assault on Site-40-R was
a daring effort, as the majority of the site
was completely overtaken by tentacles, growths,
and anomalous alterations.
While numerous altered personnel were lost
during the mission, it was ultimately a success.
Some altered personnel were able to be saved
through extensive surgery to remove their
anomalous growths.
And after everything was said and done, the
site was repaired and reconstructed without
incident.
Following the site’s repair, there has been
little activity from the entity within the
pit, but the Foundation continues to keep
an eye on the creature and the ecosystem of
the anomalous marine life that live on the
Bass Strait, never knowing what their next
move might be, and always keeping in mind
the risk that comes with dealing with these
poorly-understood entities.
A lot of us have fond memories of Halloween.
Dressing up in spooky costumes, wandering
around the neighborhood with friends while
trick or treating, getting home with literal
buckets full of candy, and then eating so
many sugary treats that you feel sick.
Halloween is a beloved holiday, especially
throughout many parts of the United States.
And if you were lucky enough to grow up in
a town that really went all out when the last
night of October rolled around, then you may
even have had a local Halloween themed fairground
to visit on the creepiest night of the year.
Scary rides, mazes, and jack o’ lanterns
as far as the eye can see.
But, with all that said, if you lived in a
certain town in the Midwest, then maybe the
county fair is a little more frightening than
the spirit of the Halloween season usually
encourages.
Settle in for a story of scares, a tale of
terror and a fable of frights, this is SCP-097,
also known as Old Fairgrounds.
Cordoned off by the SCP Foundation using huge
concrete walls is ten acres of rural land
in an undisclosed area of the Midwestern United
States.
The place itself is completely abandoned,
left silent and alone as everything contained
within those walls slowly falls into disrepair.
This is all that remains of the local County
Fair, held in the year 1969.
And right in the middle of it all?
A pickup truck, crushed and wrecked beyond
all use.
But this truck didn’t crash, oh no this
was no tragic roadside accident.
The thing that crushed it happened to be a
gigantic pumpkin.
Now, we aren’t just talking about a local
vegetable growing competition winner here.
When we say this is a big pumpkin, we are
talking huge.
The colossal squash has been recorded to measure
well over seven meters in height, with a diameter
just over eight meters at the widest point.
According to estimates, this pumpkin, known
as SCP-097-1, weighs an enormous 15,000 kilograms,
or 33,070 pounds.
To give you a frame of reference, that’s
about four times the average weight of a hippopotamus.
The pumpkin even manages to keep a perfectly
spherical shape, staying plump and round rather
than spreading out under its own weight, as
you might expect a plant of such size would.
Okay, a pickup truck crushed by a giant pumpkin?
You might be wondering, surely that can’t
be all there is?
Well, don’t you worry, we’re just getting
started with this creep show.
The rest of the surrounding area of SCP-097
is abundant in overgrown pumpkins, none that
quite reach the enviable size of SCP-097-1,
but plenty of all different subspecies and
types.
On average, these smaller pumpkins weigh around
250 kilograms, or 550 pounds.
Along with various other crops that have grown
within the area of SCP-097, the pumpkins seem
to have formed some kind of maze, no pun intended.
Get it, maize like corn?
These jokes are wasted on you.
Spooky mazes are no strange inclusion at rural
Halloween fairs like this one.
Getting lost in the middle of the night, surrounded
by rows of corn taller than a human being
is all part of the fun.
Makes a person feel like they’re right in
the middle of a classic eighties slasher movie,
where the killer could be creeping up behind
them any second.
The naturally formed labyrinth found within
SCP-097 has spread all throughout what is
left of the 1969 county fairgrounds, with
the “walls” of crops reaching over one
and a half meters tall, depending on the year.
So, is that all?
A maze of crops with one giant pumpkin at
its center?
Oh, that’s far from all there is to SCP-097.
During the time between April and November
of every year, a number of bizarre and anomalous
phenomena take place within this abandoned
county fairground, ranging from strange happenings
that defy explanation, to things that are
downright dangerous.
Since they first came into contact with SCP-097,
the Foundation have lost eight agents to the
phenomena that occur within that area, with
a another seventeen being severely maimed.
While the exact time of these events seems
to vary, the SCP Foundation keeps an extensive
record of phenomena that occur within SCP-097.
Now sometimes, these will be as harmless and
annoying as the sound of drums playing throughout
the day, for almost twenty four hours without
stopping.
Then, there’s the sightings of entities
moving through the maze only to disappear
after a few short seconds.
Security footage the Foundation’s agents
have gathered of these entities depict them
as what can only be described as “bed sheet
ghosts”, the kind you might see and immediately
think of as a last minute low budget Halloween
costume.
On one particular occasion, singing was heard
in the maze, coming from an unidentified source.
When analyzed, recordings made by the Foundation
revealed there were up to thirty children’s
voices, all singing in unintelligible gibberish
for three consecutive hours.
Another incident involved a member of personnel
on site, Agent McRoy, who cut a pumpkin vine
using a machete.
Horrifyingly, the severed vine bled.
By that we mean, actual human blood came pouring
out of the plant.
Another agent, on a separate occasion, was
also found dead within the SCP-097 maze.
Agent Long had disappeared on the way to the
restroom, only to be discovered lifeless and
bloodied, resting against a pumpkin.
During one weekly examination of SCP-097,
one Agent Cole broke open a pumpkin completely
by accident.
As the pumpkin split apart, however, to the
agent’s horror, a child’s skeleton was
revealed to be inside.
A human child’s skeleton, a little girl
crouched in the fetal position, believed to
only have been about five years of age.
Another incident saw O’Toole, a research
assistant working on site at SCP-097 experiencing
symptoms of nausea.
O’Toole also appeared to be vomiting pumpkin
seeds, despite not having eaten any recently.
Within a day, O’Toole was dead, seeming
to have died overnight in his sleep.
An autopsy conducted by Foundation experts
revealed that O’Toole’s chest cavity,
the space beneath his ribs, was somehow filled
with the same pumpkin seeds.
All of these happenings are strange to say
the least, but perhaps most concerning of
all is the effect that the abandoned fairground
of SCP-097 seems to have on children.
Any under or up to the age of ten years old
can fall victim to an unpredictable signal
that seems to emanate from SCP-097, with a
maximum range that is, as of yet, undetermined.
Usually beginning in early April, children
that are affected by this signal become afflicted
with somnambulism, or sleep walking as it
is more commonly known.
On clear nights, these children will wander
around their own homes, often only stopping
in front of closed doorways.
This behavior usually doesn’t happen often,
at least at first, only occurring once a week.
However, sleep walking gradually becomes more
frequent, and by around the middle of August,
it will be a nightly occurrence.
If children with this affliction are ever
woken up while sleepwalking, they will scream
for several seconds, before appearing confused.
This seems to be the only known way to break
the influence of SCP-097.
However, if left undisturbed, a child will
spend their sleep walking episodes familiarizing
themselves with the doorways of their house.
They will stop at every entrance, exit, garage
door, gate, even the neighbors’ front doors
once they find a way outside.
From September, the sleepwalking children
will stay outside, upright but asleep until
the sun comes up.
Many are often found laying on the grass in
their gardens, and commonly recall having
dreams about autumn-season activities.
Between September first and November first,
any affected child not awoken during their
sleepwalking will begin to migrate towards
SCP-097’s location.
All while still unconscious, they will traverse
country roads, cutting across large empty
fields, as they gradually make their way towards
the abandoned remains of the county fairground.
Once there, they will even be able to blindly
navigate a path through the maze that surrounds
most of SCP-097, until they find the center.
What happens when they make it to the center
of the maze?
Any sleepwalking children who are able to
make it that far will seek out SCP-097-1,
the gigantic pumpkin crushing the truck in
the middle of the SCP-097 area.
The children will then sit down around the
almost 23 foot tall pumpkin, and begin to
sing.
Even though the SCP Foundation have managed
to make recordings of this, much of the singing
seems to be gibberish, or at least not sung
in any known language.
However, music will also begin playing from
an unknown source, seeming to include a number
of basic instruments, most commonly simple
drums and pipes.
After the sleepwalking children have spent
a number of minutes singing like this, that
is when things take a turn for the far, far
worse, like a Charlie Brown Halloween special
straight out of your most horrific nightmares.
From the tangled mess of plants that make
up the maze within SCP-097, things will start
to emerge.
These entities will crawl out of the surrounding
flora, or will come bursting out from within
the larger of the nearby pumpkins.
They appear to be childlike in both their
appearance and mannerisms, some even wearing
pajamas or similar clothing.
Why?
Simple, because these are the children that
sleep walked before.
They are all previous victims, the ones stolen
from their families and brought into this
maze.
Still wearing the clothes that they were last
seen in; they are all the children known to
be lost to SCP-097.
What happens next is truly chilling.
The latest child that has been affected by
the draw of the pumpkin-filled fairground
will be quickly surrounded by all their fellow
victims.
The other children, if they are in fact still
human children, will encircle the newest child,
singing and dancing around them in a circle.
As they do this, a dim light begins to glow
from somewhere within SCP-097-1, the biggest
pumpkin in the center of SCP-097.
Finally, at this point in the process, the
newly affected child will wake up.
Normally, they experience a great deal of
terror and confusion.
After all, they have been unconscious throughout
this entire ordeal, sleepwalking far away
from the safety of their own home to a maze
in the middle of nowhere.
Terror is a powerful thing, enough to make
even the bravest person let out a scream.
But the moment the now awakened child lets
out any sound, that is when they are doomed.
Should they scream, cry or make any form of
vocal noise, then the others will swarm them.
The other children, the ones previously lured
into SCP-097 while sleep walking, will attack
the terrified newcomer.
Each time is different, sometimes they will
claw at the new child, other times they might
bite or kick.
The methods are always different, but most
often this swarm of the pumpkin’s previous
victims will strangle or dismember the latest
visitor to the abandoned fairground.
At this point, there is no saving the latest
victim.
Any attempt to interfere will only fail, either
the children will all become intangible, or
another violent phenomenon will occur within
SCP-097, stopping any onlooker from saving
the child’s life.
When the deed is finally done, and the latest
victim has been killed by the other children,
the gigantic pumpkin at the heart of SCP-097
will open.
Its side will split like a pair of great,
devouring jaws, and the children will throw
the body of the newest child into SCP-097-1.
Once the body has been disposed of, these
entities, once children that sleep walked
away from their families, will follow, crawling
into the pumpkin before it closes and the
music finally stops.
The exact number of children between the ages
of three and ten years of age who have been
lost to SCP-097 is currently kept secret by
the Foundation.
And perhaps, for all of our sanities, that
is for the best.
Like we said, a lot of us have fond memories
of Halloween.
But not all
of us...